GOOD AFTERNOON -- I'M CENTER
BILL DODD -- ONE OF THE CULTURES
OF THE SENATE -- SELECT
COMMITTEE ON WHY YEAH THAT'S MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY -- TO
KICK OFF THIS -- HEARING.
I FIRST WANTED TO DO WAS --
INTRODUCE -- DANIEL -- L. PETRI
WHO IS THE DEAN OF THE SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMICS.
SIR HOW ARE YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR LOTT.
IT'S MY PLEASURE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE OUR PRESIDENT.
WILL WELCOME YOU.
DR JUDITH KAYE SAKAKI BECAME SO
ALMOST A UNIVERSITY SEVEN
PRESIDENT.
ON JULY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SO ALMOST
EIGHT IS ONE OF TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WHICH IS AS YOU
PROBABLY ALL KNOW.
THE LARGEST PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY.
SHE'S THE FIRST JAPANESE
AMERICAN WOMAN.
IN THE NATION TO FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY.
DR SAKAKI IS THE RECIPIENT OF
NUMEROUS COMMUNITY LEADERSHIP
AWARDS.
SHE WAS RECOGNIZED AS PRESIDENT
OF THE YEAR IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
DR SAKAKI GREW UP IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA.
AND WAS A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT.
SHE HEARD HERE I'M SORRY SHE
EARNED HER BA IN HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT.
HER M. MASS IN EDUCATIONAL
PSYCHOLOGY BOTH FROM C. ISSUE
EASTBAY.
AND PHD IN EDUCATION FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY.
SHE SERVES ON NUMEROUS LOCAL AND
NATIONAL BOARDS AND SPEAKS ABOUT
LEADERSHIP AND RESILIENT.
HAVING BEEN A VICTIM OF THE TUBS
FIRE WHICH DESTROYED MORE THAN
FIVE THOUSAND HOMES IN CINEMA
COUNTY.
IN OCTOBER.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DR SPOCK
SAKAKI.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
WELCOME TO CINEMA STATE AND
WELCOME TO THE WINE SPECTATOR
LEARNING CENTER WE ARE DELIGHTED
AND WE'RE REALLY HONORED. TO
HAVE YOU ON CAMPUS FOR THIS
JOINT SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
HEARING.
HERE IT'S ENORMOUS DAY WE WORK
REALLY HARD TO REUSE AND RECYCLE
THINGS AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
AND THIS BEAUTIFUL WINE
SPECTATOR LEARNING CENTER IS A
WONDERFUL PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
THIS THIS USED TO BE OUR OLD
STUDENT UNION -- OUR CAFETERIA
AND BOOKSTORE AND WHILE LOOK AT
IT NOW IT STANDS AS A SYMBOL OF
CINEMA STATES RECOGNITION.
AS THE NATION'S PREMIER
UNIVERSITY FOR THE STUDY AND
RESEARCH OF THE BUSINESS OF WINE.
WE HELD A RIBBON CUTTING
CEREMONY HERE.
JUST ABOUT A YEAR AGO.
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE
FILLED THIS BEAUTIFUL CENTER AND
OUT ON THE AREAS AROUND IT.
AND TOOK PART IN THE CELEBRATION
ON THAT DAY MANY OF YOU WERE
ABLE TO JOIN US.
WHAT I REMEMBER MOST ABOUT THAT
SUNNY AFTERNOON WAS THE
EXCITEMENT AND THE ANTICIPATION
AND THE ENERGY?
OF THE CROWD.
THERE WERE SPEECHES.
THERE WAS LAUGHTER AND OF COURSE
THERE WAS CHAMPAGNE IN LINE.
BUT MOST OF ALL IT WAS JOY AND
ANTICIPATION.
ANTICIPATION OF WHAT THIS
FACILITY WHAT THIS BUILDING
COULD DO FOR US.
WE HOPED AND ENVISION THAT WHEN
WE OPEN THE STORES.
THAT THIS TYPE OF GATHERING WAS
EXACTLY WHAT WE WOULD BECOME
KNOWN FOR A PLACE TO EDUCATE. TO
LEARN.
AND MOST OF ALL TO GATHER AND TO
GROW TOGETHER IN PURSUIT OF
MAKING OUR WORLD A LITTLE
SMALLER.
A LITTLE SMARTER A LITTLE MORE
CONNECTED MORE COLLABORATIVE
MORE CARING MORE RESILIENT AND A
BIT BETTER.
AND FOR THAT.
WE HAVE MANY PEOPLE TO OFFER
THINGS AND TO GIVE CREDIT.
THE WINE SPECTATOR LEARNING
CENTER IS AN IDEA THAT WAS
CONCEIVED YEARS AGO BY GARY HECK
PRESIDENT AND OWNER OF CORBELL
WINERY.
PRESIDENT EMERITUS RUBEN ARMEN
JANA AND MANY OTHERS WHO HAD
THIS VISION.
IT WAS AN IDEA THAT WAS BROUGHT
TO FRUITION BY WINE SPECTATOR
ANDY.
EDITOR AND PUBLISHER MARVIN
SHANKEN OUR WINE BUSINESS
INSTITUTE BOARD MEMBERS AND
OTHERS WHO'S GIVING WHOSE VISION
AND PERSISTENCE MADE THIS ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR RENOVATION.
POSSIBLE.
AND IT'S AN IDEA THAT IS
VALIDATED AND ENRICHED BY YOUR
PRESENCE HERE TODAY AND HAVING
THIS HEARING HERE.
THIS BUILDING IS HOME TO THE
UNIVERSITY'S ONE BUSINESS
INSTITUTE WHICH REPRESENTS A
VERY UNIQUE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
OUR SCHOOL OF BUSINESS AND
ECONOMICS.
AND THE WINE INDUSTRY.
THIS PARTNERSHIP HAS FOSTERED
THE EDUCATION AND DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW WINE INDUSTRY LEADERS MANY
OF WHOM I'VE HAD A CHANCE TO
MEET MANY OF OUR LOANS TODAY.
IT'S STRENGTHEN TIES BETWEEN OUR
UNIVERSITY THE WINE COUNTRY AND
WINE LEADERS AROUND THE WORLD.
AND THIS PARTNERSHIP HAS GIVEN
RISE TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INNOVATIVE NEW PROGRAMS ONE
PIONEERING INITIATIVE THAT I AM
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF IS ONE
THAT WE CALL OUR WINE INDUSTRY
SCHOLARS PROGRAM.
WHICH OFFERS SCHOLARSHIPS TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILY MEMBERS OF
VINEYARD AND WINERY WORKERS MANY
OF WHOM ARE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SO THROUGH PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
THIS CENTER REFLECTS THE PILLARS
OF CINEMA STATES NEWLY REVISED
STRATEGIC PLAN.
WITH PRIORITY SETTING FOOD
STUDENT SUCCESS.
LEADERSHIP CULTIVATION AND
ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE AND
INNOVATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK AND
RECOGNISE OUR LOCAL LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS ARE CO CHAIRS AND SHARE
OF THIS CONVENING.
SENATOR BILL DODD SENATOR MIKE
MCGUIRE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SINCE YOU YES AS WE ARE CURRY
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'LL HEAR
FROM THEM IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT YOUR
ONGOING ADVICE.
YOUR PARTNERSHIP YOUR FRIENDSHIP.
I REALLY APPRECIATE OUR MEETINGS
IN SACRAMENTO PHONE CALLS THAT
YOU TAKE FOR ME.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU DO IN
SERVICE TO OUR STATE.
OUR REGION OUR CAMPUS AND
COMMUNITY AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING.
THIS JOINT HEARING HERE TO OUR
CAMPUS.
WITH GRATITUDE AND MUCH
APPRECIATION WELCOME TO ALL OF
YOU.
WELCOME TO YOUR UNIVERSITY
WELCOME TO CINEMAS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PRESENCES SUCKS A
COCKY REALLY APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU AND YOUR TEAM OPENING THIS
UP FOR US TODAY I'D BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS MEETING HERE GRANT
ASKED TO BE.
BACK ON CAMPUS THIS BEAUTIFUL
BUILDING.
ALSO I TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK -- AND APPRECIATE MY
CALLING SIDE -- GERMAN MCGUIRE
AND AND CHAIRWOMAN I SINCERELY
I. GAR CURRY -- WE RUN THESE
COMMITTEES IN A LOT OF THE
ASSEMBLY SENATE THERE ARE
SEPARATE.
THEY'LL HAVE THEIR OWN SEPARATE
HEARINGS.
WE PREFER TO WORK TOGETHER TO
BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER TO WHAT
TO FEWER MEETINGS INSTEAD OF
MANY MANY MEETINGS SO IT'S A
MORE EFFICIENT I THINK NOT FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THE BUSINESS.
THE MEMBERS G. ACADEMIC --
COMMUNITY AS WELL NOT TO HAVE TO
BE TRAVELING ALL OVER THE PLACE --
YOU KNOW ALL THE TIME.
SO -- I'M ALSO FORTUNATE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A YOU KNOW WHAT.
SNOW MISTAKE -- ALARM IN G. U.
C. DAVIS -- ONE ALL OVER MY
DISTRICT BUT ALSO ON MY STAFF
AND THAT'S KIND OF FUN -- HAVING
THEM COME BACK WE HAVE LOGAN
IT'S IT'S HERE TODAY IT'S ON MY
TEAM THAT -- WHEN HERE BUT YOU
KNOW THESE INSTITUTIONS UC DAVIS
STUFF ESTATE ARE LEADING THE WAY
IN WINE EDUCATION?
BUT WE ALSO HAVE AMAZING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SNOWMEN
NAP AS WELL WITH EXCELLENT WHITE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
TODAY'S FIRST PANEL WILL BE THE
STATE OF THE WINE INDUSTRY
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH IT WILL
BE MODERATED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGAR CURRY.
OUR SECOND PANEL WILL BE ON
EMERGING MARKETS IN APPELLATIONS
MODERATED BY SENATOR MCGUIRE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
AGAIN FOR BEING HERE TODAY AN
ALTERNATE OVER TO MY CO CHAIR
CENTER MCGUIRE FOR SOME OPENING
REMARKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS SENATOR
DODD IN -- GRATEFUL -- IN ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE IS WE
WANT TO WELCOME YOU AND AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AT
PERSONALLY I SPENT SOME.
QUALITY YEARS HERE AT CINEMA
STAYED A LITTLE LONGER THAN I
THOUGHT SINCE I COULDN'T PASS IT.
TO SIX BUT I I GOTTA SAY FROM
WHERE THIS BUILDING WAS TO WHERE
IT IS TODAY IT'S NINE DAY -- AND
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
DEDICATION S. NO MISTAKE FOR
TURNING REALLY THAT WAS DOOM AND
GLOOM IN THIS -- CENTER -- TO
WHAT IS JUST OUTSTANDING AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE A CULTURE DODD.
AND AS SOON AS WE ARE CURRY
WHO'S THE CHAIR WOMAN ON THIS
THE ASSEMBLY SITE THEY DO
AMAZING WORK.
DAY IN AND DAY OUT ON BEHALF OF
BAG IN -- ONE AND I THINK WE
NEED TO GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE.
SIX I THINK THAT -- YOU AGREE
WITH US THAT THERE ARE VERY FEW
VERY FEW INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE
HAD SUCH A POSITIVE ECONOMIC
IMPACT IN COMMUNITIES BIG AND
SMALL ACROSS THE STATE.
IN THE WINE INDUSTRY BUT FOR
TODAY -- WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
PAN US ARE GONNA BE GIVING US AN
UPDATE ON THE ALL IMPORTANT NEXT
GENERATION OF WINE LEADERS --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM TEACHERS AND STUDENTS IN MY
NAME THREE EXPERTS ON HOW TO
HELP THIS NEXT GENERATION CREATE
THE FINEST WINES IN THE WORLD.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE HEARING
FROM EMERGING MARKETS IN YOU
APPELLATIONS IN THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES
THAT COME WITH IT.
SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT ONCE YOU
HAVE YOUR NEW APPELLATION
DESIGNATED YOUR WORKERS OVER.
IF YOU'RE IN INDUSTRY YOU KNOW
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT THE M.
TRUE.
HI WORKING HERE THIS AFTERNOON --
FROM THEM HOW TO BE ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH IT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING HOW OUR COMMITTEES
CAN BE ASSISTANCE YOU.
AS ALWAYS WE LIKE TO THINK THE
WINE INSTITUTE FOR THE WORK WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
PRESIDENT PRESENTS A COCKY FOR
HAVING US HERE AND OF COURSE THE
CINEMA STATE FOR BEING OUR HOST
IS WELL.
WOULD LIKE TO BE RICHARD OVER --
CULTURE DODD THE WORK SHE SIR
BACK TO THE GOOD IS IN THE WOMAN
THE CHAIR OF THE ONE SELECTED
FOR THE C. DECEMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I WANNA
THANK YOU AND GIVE THE
HOSPITALITY DAY I WAS LOVELY.
UP LAST WEEK TO BE HERE.
PUBLIC POLICY LAW AND
REGULATIONS IN THE EIGHTY FIVE
AND THEY WERE VERY LIKE --
ENERGIZE ASK ME AND TELL ME WHAT
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED IN THE
INDUSTRY AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND THE INTERESTING PART ABOUT
THIS I'M A FARMER -- EYES I'M A
SMALL FARMER EIGHTY ACRES OF ON
THE THERE'S IS THAT WE NEED TO
FIND OUT WHAT THE OPPORTUNITIES
ARE FOR YOU THE CHALLENGES YOU
HAVE WHERE CAN WE GO WHAT'S THAT
AGAIN.
I'M WITH THE EDUCATION HOW DO WE
GET SOME OF OUR SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND WE'RE STRUGGLING IN MANY OF
THAT HUESO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HAVING US TODAY I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION AND I
LOOK FORWARD.
TO A LIVELY CONVERSATION
HOPEFULLY FOR SOME QUESTION
ANSWER LATER ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ALL RIGHT SO THE FIRST PANEL
TODAY.
WE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE WINE INDUSTRY
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH -- RAY
JOHNSON IS JOINING US EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR -- SADDAM STATE
UNIVERSITY ONE BUSINESS
INSTITUTE.
DAVID BLOCK UC DAVIS DEPARTMENT
CHAIR OF THE CULTURE AND IN
OLOGY.
CLAIRE HOBDAY FROM THE A C. F.
O. FROM A MONDAVI AND FAMILY.
SHANNON WALKER HIDE THE STATE
MANAGER HYDE ESTATE WINERY AND
TONY STEVEN BOARD CHAIRMAN
AMERICAN VINEYARD FOUNDATION
WELCOME.
AND WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST
HEART RATE.
GOING UP FIRST OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATORS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS HEARING TO CAMPUS
MEANS A LOT.
TO OUR VISION IS TO BE THE
GLOBAL LEADER IN ONE BUSINESS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION HERE AT
CINEMA STATE.
AND THIS ALL GOT STARTED.
YOU SEE BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX TWENTY THREE YEARS AGO NOW --
WAS AN IDEA THAT WAS PUT FORWARD
BY GERRY HECHO NORTH CORBELL IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR PRESENT AT
THE TIME ARYANA.
AND HE EXPLAINED A REAL NEED
THAT WE HAD IN WIND AND THAT WAS
PREPARING FOR SUCCESSION
PLANNING WHO IS GOING TO LEAD
THE NEXT GENERATION WHO WERE
GOING TO TAKE OVER THE RUNNING
OF THE WINERIES HERE IN THE
NORTH COAST TO CONTINUE.
THEIR SUCCESS IN A VERY
COMPETITIVE MARKET PLACE.
SO HE RECRUITED WALL CLANS HE
WAS RUNNING BERINGER AT THE TIME
AND THEN ALSO HENRY TREE MONNING.
THEY BILL TO BOARD OF DIRECTORS
ONE IN APPLE ONE IN CINEMA
WORKING TOGETHER ACROSS THE MIKE
ON THIS MOUNTAIN.
AND THAT GROUP.
BECAME A GROUP OF TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN PEOPLE WORKING
TOGETHER ON OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS TODAY AND THEY REALLY
PROVIDE THE STRATEGIC DIRECTION
FOR OUR PROGRAMS OUR RESEARCH.
AND ALL THE ACTIVITIES THAT TAKE
PLACE HERE IN THE WINE BUSINESS
INSTITUTE.
YOU CAN SEE THE COMPANIES THAT
THEY REPRESENT THEIR WINERIES
LARGE AND SMALL BUT ALSO OTHER
PEOPLE WORKING ALONG THE VALUE
CHAIN -- IN ACCOUNTING IN THE
LAW -- SERVICE IN THE INDUSTRY
WITH PRODUCTS BEFORE THEY MAKE
WINE AND SELLING AND MARKETING
THE WINE AFTER ITS PRODUCE.
THIS IS THE PUBLIC PART OF THE
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THE
DOCTOR SAKAKI DESCRIBE OUR
FACULTY FACULTY IN THE BUILDING
SEASONED ACADEMICS WHO ARE
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD OF WINE
BUSINESS RESEARCH.
BUT ALSO.
PRACTITIONERS FROM THE INDUSTRY --
WE HAVE A CLASS GOING TODAY WITH
OUR EXECUTIVE ONE MBA STUDENTS
AND ONE OF OUR FACULTY IS HERE
HAD A LONG TERM.
INTEREST AND ROLE IN HR AND THE
WINE INDUSTRY TO BRING THAT
EXPERTISE COUPLED WITH OUR
ACADEMIC FACULTY IT'S JUST MAGIC
[INAUDIBLE]
SO.
I MENTIONED THE VISION AND WE
HAVE A BIG STAKE IN RESEARCH AND
THE FACULTY HAS BEEN WORKING ON
THAT AS WELL AS THE CURRICULUM
THAT'S VERY FOCUSED ON INDUSTRY
ISSUES.
WHEN WE PRESENTED AT THE
FINANCIAL SYMPOSIUM LAST FALL?
THESE WERE THE ISSUES AND
CONCERNS THAT THE INDUSTRY
IDENTIFIED AS MOST SALIENT AND
MOST CRITICAL RIGHT NOW.
IN THE ONE ON WORKFORCE
CONTINUES IT'S CHALLENGING AND
IT'S NOT THE COST OF LABOR IT'S
JUST SIMPLY THE AVAILABILITY OF
PEOPLE TO FILL THE ROLES THAT WE
HAVE IN THE KNEES.
OTHER THINGS AS WELL AND NATURAL
DISASTERS HAS BECOME QUITE A
CONCERN AND WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT A MORE ABOUT THAT TODAY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO A LITTLE
DEEPER DIVE INTO RESEARCH AND
THAT'S TALK ABOUT AN ASSESSMENT
OF THE NORTH COAST WILDFIRES
THAT WE DID BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IF YOU
WATCH THE COVERAGE IT WAS
DEVASTATING -- MANY PEOPLE LOST
HOMES LIVES BUILDINGS PROPERTY
AND BUSINESSES WERE IMPACTED.
BUT THE THE MISSTEP ON CNN AND
OTHER PROVIDERS OF THE CONTENT.
THEY GAVE THE IMPRESSION THAT
THE WINE INDUSTRY WAS CLOSE.
AND THE BOARD GAVE US A CHARGE
YES IN THE BOARD GAVE US THE
CHARGE THEY SAID LOOK WE NEED TO
DOCUMENT THE TRUTH.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT VINEYARDS
WEREN'T BURNED REALLY A SMALL
NUMBER IN A SMALL NUMBER OF
WINERIES DISPLAY SO WE WENT OUT
AND GOT THE NUMBERS WE FIND OUT
THAT NINETY NINE POINT 8% OF
VINEYARD ACRES IN THE NORTH
COAST WERE UNAFFECTED BY THE
FIRES.
SO WE BEGAN -- PROCESS OF
GETTING THAT WORD OUT THROUGH
THE MEDIA AND THROUGH OUR OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE INDUSTRY TO
HELP WRITE THE SHIP ON THAT
STORY BECAUSE IT WAS REALLY A
DEVASTATING ECONOMIC IMPACT. TO
HAVE THE TOURIST NOT COM.
ANOTHER AREA THAT WE'VE WORKED
ON OR THE COMMUNITY PERCEPTIONS
OF WINE BUSINESSES IN THE NORTH
COAST.
ALMOST TO A PERSON PEOPLE REALLY
LIKE WINE IN THIS AREA THEY LIVE
HERE THEY TAKE THEIR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY TO VISIT WINERIES THEY
LOVE THE P. CALL LIKE ASPECT OF
THE VINEYARDS -- IT'S PRETTY
BEAUTIFUL -- WE LIVE IN A GREAT
REGION THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
NORTH COAST.
THE MIKE CAME HE'S GONNA TALK A
LITTLE BIT LATER FROM THIS
NUMBER CONNIE VENDORS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES LOCALLY SOMETIMES
WHEN YOU WANT TO START A NEW
WINE BUSINESS.
YOU WANT TO PUT IN THE NEW
VINEYARD OR PERHAPS MODIFYING
EXISTING PERMIT IT CAME IF YOU
WERE AT SOME OF THE HEARINGS YOU
THINK THAT ONE WAS BIG OIL.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF HYPERBOLE
THROWN AROUND.
YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN.
THEN.
SO THIS WASN'T.
SO AGAIN THE BOARD TASKED US
WITH HE THAT'S GET THE FACTS ON
THIS AND SO WE COMMISSIONED A
STUDY WE DID THE RESEARCH AND
HERE'S WHAT WE FOUND. 7474% OF
RESIDENTS IN THE NORTH COAST
HAVE A VERY POSITIVE IMPRESSION
OF THE WINE INDUSTRY 4% NEGATIVE.
AND WE DON'T SEE THOSE KIND OF
NUMBERS ON ANYTHING SEVENTY FOUR
VERSUS FOUR THEY HAD A LITTLE
SLICE IN THE MIDDLE THAT'S JUST
FINE EVERYTHING'S MEN'S THE
MEN'S.
SO THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
DOCUMENT.
AND THAT HAS BEEN A HELP TO
LOCAL PEOPLE -- AND LOCAL
LEADERS LIKE MIKE IN CARRYING
THE MESSAGE FORWARD AT PLANNING
COMMISSION MEETINGS -- ANOTHER
IMPORTANT THING TO DOCUMENT HAS
BEEN THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
WINE INDUSTRY AND WHAT A CRUCIAL
ROLE THEY CRY THEY PLAY IN JOB
CREATION NOT ONLY IN WINERIES.
AND VINEYARDS BUT ALSO THROUGH
THE WHOLE VALUE CHAIN OF CHANGE
THAT IS SUPPORTED BY THE SUCCESS
OF THIS INDUSTRY.
AND THE PUBLIC RECOGNIZES IT AND
ALSO THE PUBLIC RECOGNIZES HOW
PHILANTHROPIC WINE INDUSTRY IS.
IT'S A IT'S AN AMAZING VIRTUOUS
CIRCLE YOU SEE OF GIVING WHERE.
99% OF THE WINERIES IN THE NORTH
COAST SPECIFICALLY TARGET
THEY'RE GIVING TO THE LOCAL
INTERESTS VERY VERY LOCALLY
MINDED.
AND DR SAKAKI MENTIONED THE WINE
INDUSTRY SCHOLARS PROGRAM.
ALREADY OVER THREE MILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO
THAT PROGRAM THAT PROGRAM
DIRECTLY SUPPORTS FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO STUDY ONE THEY CAN
STUDY WHATEVER THEY WANT.
BUT WE WANT PEOPLE WHO'VE WHOSE
PARENTS HAVE WORKED IN WINE
YOU'VE WORKED IN AGRICULTURE
MORE BROADLY WE WANT THEIR
CHILDREN TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET AN EDUCATION WHATEVER
THEY CHOOSE TO STUDY HERE IT'S
AND I'M A STATE.
IT'S REALLY MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
AND THEN EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
WE HAD A REPORTED ARE NOVEMBER
BOARD MEETING FROM SOME OF THE
FACULTY AND IT WAS IT WAS
STARTLING -- THEY WENT ON AND
DOCUMENTED THE PREPAREDNESS OR
UNDER PREPAREDNESS OF MANY -- IN
THE WINE BUSINESS AND THIS IS IN
THE FALL BUT IT'S JUST -- WE'RE
NOT READY FOR EVERY EVERY
TRAGEDY THAT CAN COME OUR WAY
AND THEY DOCUMENTED THE BEST
PRACTICES AND SOME OF THE BEST
CASES THAT THEY FOUND WITH
WINERIES ARE DOING IT REALLY
WELL.
AND AT OUR SUMMIT ON JULY TENTH
HERE OR RESEARCH SUMMIT WE'RE
GONNA PRESENT THOSE FINDINGS
WE'RE GONNA SHARE THEM WITH THE
INDUSTRY AND PROVIDE TAKEN
MATERIALS THAT PEOPLE CAN PUT TO
WORK.
AT THEIR ONE BUSINESSES IN
VINEYARDS.
AND IT SPEAKS TO SOMETHING THAT
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS AT OUR
MAY MEETING ASKED ME TO BRING
FORWARD THEY GAVE ME THIS CHARGE.
ASK OUR LEGISLATORS IF THEY
WOULD HELP SUPPORT SOME OF THIS
RESEARCH THAT WE'RE DOING ONE
ONE BUSINESS.
AND SO THAT IS MY ASK FOR YOU
TODAY IF WE COULD WORK TOGETHER
TO IDENTIFY -- FINDING WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS OR
PERHAPS CONNECTION THE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS IN SACRAMENTO
THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
SOME OF THIS RESEARCH THAT WE'RE
DOING SPECIFICALLY ON THE
BUSINESS OF WINE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING WE
COULD DO [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THAT IS AWESOME.
WELL I APPRECIATED.
ALL BOY AND AGAIN YOU KNOW OUR
VISION.
IT'S TWO FOLD IT'S ON RESEARCH
BUT ALSO ON PROGRAMS SO LET'S
TURN TO THE PROGRAMS FOR A
MINUTE.
WE STARTED OUR BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN WINE BUSINESS FIRST ONE IN
THE HEMISPHERE FIRST WHEN THE
UNITED STATES AND OF COURSE THE
WHOLE HEMISPHERE WE STARTED A
GRADUATE DEGREE IN ONE BUSINESS.
AND TODAY OUR FLAGSHIP PROGRAM
IS THIS OUR EXECUTIVE ONE NBA
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM TWO OF
OUR ALUMNI FROM THE PROGRAM
TODAY THIS IS THE GROUP THAT
GRADUATED LAST SUMMER.
AND IT'S AMAZING THE CAREERS
THAT THEY'RE DEVELOPING.
THEY THEY EXPERIENCE THE WORLD
ON OUR INTERNATIONAL TRIP --
THIS PAST MARCH WE WERE IN --
EUROPE WITH THE CURRENT GROUP OF
STUDENTS THEY WERE LOOKING AT
HOW ONE BUSINESS IS DONE THE
CHALLENGES IN FRANCE THE
CHALLENGES IN GREECE -- THE
OPPORTUNITIES IN BOTH OF WHAT WE
CAN LEARN FROM SOMEBODY WHO'S IN
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PARADIGM --
WE GO SAILING TOGETHER ON THE
SAN DIEGO BAY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN LEADERSHIP
SKILLS IS TREMENDOUS WHEN YOU
HAVE TO SAIL A SHIP TOGETHER
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
YOU CAN'T JUST HAVE ONE ROCKSTAR
EVERYBODY'S GOT A POOL THEIR
PART.
IT'S QUITE A PROGRAM AND I WANNA
LET YOU KNOW WE'RE IN ROLLING
RIGHT NOW FOR THE NEXT ITERATION
IN THIS GRADUATE PROGRAM THAT'S
OUR GLOBAL ONE NBA.
IT'S A BLEND OF ON CAMPUS BUT A
LOT OF ONLINE OPPORTUNITY WHICH
WILL MAKE THE PROGRAM ACCESSIBLE
FOR PEOPLE WITH A GREATER
DISTANCE ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT I THANK YOU I'M SO
GLAD YOU CAME HERE TODAY
APPRECIATE [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
TO ALL THREE OF YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO BE HERE -- SO WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO TODAY IS SPEND A FEW
MINUTES TO BRING YOU UP TO DATE
ON WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
NO G. YOU C. DAVIS -- ORDERS
VERY COMPLIMENTARY TO WORK WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT -- WE FOCUS
MUCH MORE ON THE TECHNICAL SIDE
OF THINGS -- IS THERE FOCUSING
MORE ON THE BUSINESS -- JUST
BRIEFLY UC DAVIS -- AS I THINK
OF YOU KNOW IS -- IS PART OF THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
IT'S THE LAND GRANT -- ONE OF
THE MAIN LINGERING CAMPUSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK THE KEY THING IS
HERE TO KEEP THINGS ONE IS IT'S
IT IS THE TOP.
PROGRAM IN AGRICULTURE IN THE
COUNTRY ONE OF THE TOP. TWO IN
THE WORLD PROBABLY.
AND THAT MEANS THAT WHILE I'M
GOING TO FOCUS ON THE DEPARTMENT
VITICULTURE ANALOGY -- THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE RESEARCHERS
STUDENTS FOCUSED ON AGRICULTURE
IN GENERAL IS MUCH BROADER THAN
IN OUR DEPARTMENT AND WE TAKE
ADVANTAGE THAT ALONG THE WAY AS
WELL.
THE THE HISTORY OF OUR
DEPARTMENT STARTS ACTUALLY IN IN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY AND IT STARTS
WITH THE ACT FROM YOU FROM THE
STATE LEGISLATURE -- BECAUSE AT
THAT POINT THE STATE ALREADY
KNEW THE GRAPES ONE WE'RE GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT TO THE ECONOMY
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THEY DECIDED THAT THERE
NEEDED TO BE A PLACE TO TRAIN --
TRAIN PEOPLE TO GROW GRAPES AND
MAKE.
ONE COURSE AT THAT POINT THE
ONLY CAMPUS SERVES UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA WAS A BERKELEY AND
THE DEPARTMENT STARTED THERE IN --
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY IT SUPPORTED THE
GROWTH OF THE THAT FIRST KIND OF
GROWTH OF THE INDUSTRY AND THE
THE LATE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
AND THEN -- AFTER THE END OF
PROHIBITION MOVED OUT TO DAVIS
WORDED IT'S BEEN SENSE -- AND IS
IS REALLY CREDITED FIRST --
HELPING THE INDUSTRY TO RECOVER
FROM PROHIBITION AND TO REGAIN
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WAS LOST
DURING THOSE THIRTEEN YEARS.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS HAS COME UP
WITH NEW KNOWLEDGE NEW
TECHNOLOGY -- AND I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTLY TRAINED STUDENTS
THAT GO OUT INTO INDUSTRY -- FOR
MANY YEARS NOW -- THROUGH THE
END OF PROHIBITION AND THEN
THROUGH THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
WERE THERE SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES
WERE.
FEWER THAN A HUNDRED WINERIES TO
PRESENT DAY WHERE THERE'S NO
MORE THAN FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
WINERIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR OUR DEPARTMENT HAS
HELPED. TO TWO FOR FUEL AND
SUPPORT THEIR GROWTH.
WE DO THAT WITH THREE A CORE
MISSIONS -- THAT'S TEACHING
RESEARCH AND EXTENSION AND I
LIKE TO SPEND A FEW MINUTES
TALKING ABOUT EACH OF THESE
BECAUSE I THINK THEY'RE ALL ALL
THREE OF THESE ARE IMPORTANT.
IN -- AND HELPING THE INDUSTRY
TO BE STRONG AND TO GROW IN THE
WAY IT WOULD LIKE.
TO AND SPORT THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS THAT COME FROM INDUSTRY
AS WELL.
SO START WITH RESEARCH -- WE
HAVE A SIXTEEN FACULTY MEMBERS
IN THE DEPARTMENT -- THE COVER A
WIDE RANGE OF DISCIPLINE
ACADEMIC DISCIPLINES MY
BACKGROUND IN CHEMICAL
ENGINEERING AND WE HAVE A FEW
CHEMICAL ENGINEERS BUT WE ALSO
CHEMISTS AND MICROBIOLOGISTS.
AND CENTURY SCIENTIST AND A
WHOLE RANGE OF PLANT BIOLOGISTS
FROM VERY BASIC TO REPLY
[INAUDIBLE]
HAVING THIS [INAUDIBLE]
THIS.
KIND OF GROUP OF ACADEMICS IN
ONE DEPARTMENT IS ACTUALLY
FAIRLY UNIQUE IN THE WORLD.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY OUR
DEPARTMENT.
IS -- CONSISTENTLY THOUGHT OF AS
THE TOP PROGRAM IN GRAPE GROWING
WINEMAKING IN THE WORLD -- THESE
ARE THE KIND OF DISCIPLINES THAT
YOU NEED TO SOLVE.
IMPORTANT PROBLEMS THAT ARE
FACING THE INDUSTRY THAT ARE
EITHER ACUTE PROBLEMS OR CHRONIC
PROBLEMS.
THAT NEED CONSTANT TENSION.
THAT INCLUDES THINGS LIKE --
USING WATER EFFICIENTLY WATER
CALIFORNIA IS OBVIOUSLY A HUGE
ISSUE.
IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN -- AND WE
HAVE RESEARCHERS ARE WORKING ON
NEW WAYS OF USING WATER
EFFICIENTLY WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
NEW PLANTS. FOR NEW WAYS OF
DISTRIBUTING WATER THROUGH THEN
YOU'RE.
BUT ALSO LONG TERM PROBLEMS LIKE
DISEASES AND CONTROLLING
DISEASES AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AS WELL.
MORE RECENTLY WE'VE HAD A HUGE
ISSUES WITH THE WILDFIRES AS
RICK MENTIONED.
AND YOU CAN SEE IN THE UPPER
LEFT HAND CORNER.
WHEN THOSE PROBLEMS STARTED
HAPPENING AND AND -- TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NEED OVER
HOLSTER WHO'S THE PERSON IN THE
MASK ON THE RATE THAT PICTURE.
WAS OUR EXTENSION I'LL JUST JUMP
RIGHT IN TO USE THAT TRAGEDY AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY STUDY
WAYS OF MITIGATING SMOKE TAINTED.
ONE WHERE AS WE GO AROUND THE
STATE WE LOOK FOR WHAT ARE THE
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING ONE
MYSTERY FOR MANY YEARS IT WAS
WATER.
AND WATER IN WATER AND WATER --
JUST IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS I
THINK LABOR HAS SURPASSED THAT
ISSUE AS THE KEY ISSUE ON THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF ONE ACHING.
AND SORE DRESSING AS WELL
THROUGH -- AUTOMATION AND
MECHANIZATION.
THE IMPACT OF WHAT WE DO FOR
RESEARCH -- WE'VE STUDIED WITH --
COLLEAGUES ON A CULTURAL
ECONOMICS DEPARTMENT YOU C.
DAVIS.
IT'S TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS WILL COME OUT OF THE
RESEARCH -- FROM OUR DEPARTMENT
AND THIS KIND OF INVESTMENT --
AS RE WAS SAYING KIND OF
INVESTMENT WHETHER IT'S FROM THE
INDUSTRY MITCHELL HERE ABOUT
MORRELL A BIT.
MORE FROM THE STATE WE'RE WHEN
THAT'S BEEN AVAILABLE HAS BEEN
HUGE THE PAY BACK IS HUGE AND
RESEARCH -- TOWARDS THE THE WELL
BEING OF THE THE INDUSTRY AND
THE STATE.
WITHOUT ONE OF THE OTHER KEY
MISSIONS THAT WE HAVE IS
TEACHING AND TRAINING STUDENTS
TO BE IN THE INDUSTRY.
WE OFFER BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND A
MASTER'S DEGREE BOTH OF THE
CULTURE AND OLOGY.
A BACHELORS DEGREE GRADUATES
ABOUT FORTY FIVE STUDENTS YEAR
AND A MASTER'S DEGREE --
GRADUATES ABOUT FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY STUDENTS HERE.
WELL THESE PROGRAMS HAVE A CORE
BASE -- CORE OF BASIC SCIENCE
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE TRAINED
IN BASIC SCIENCE BEFORE THE HAVE
INTENSIVE TRAINING.
AND THE CULTURE ANALOGY -- THIS
TRAINING IS HANDS ON AND WHAT WE
REALLY WANT FOR GRADUATES IS TO
BE. TO HAVE THE TOOL BOX THAT
LETS THEM GO OUT AND BE CREATIVE
PROBLEM SOLVERS.
THE HANDS ON EXPERIENCES IS
REALLY IMPORTANT -- AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE TEACH -- IT'S A
HANDS ON INDUSTRY AND STUDENTS
NEED TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING
BEFORE THEY GET OUT TO INDUSTRY --
SO WHETHER IT'S IN THE CHEMISTRY
LAB IS SHOWN HERE ANALYZING ONCE
CHEMICALLY.
WE'RE LEARNING HOW TO ESTABLISH
WHEN YOURS IS YOU SEE HERE. FOR
PRUNING IN THE VINEYARD ALL OF
OUR COURSES HAVE SOME KIND OF
PRACTICAL ASPECT TO IT HERE IN
THE WINERY -- WHERE STUDENTS ARE
LEARNING IN THE VINEYARD AND IN
THE WINERY AND IN THE LAB HOW TO
DO THE JOBS THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE DOING -- SHORTLY AS THEY
ENTER THE INDUSTRY.
I SHOULD SAY THAT IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TO NOTE THAT THE
STUDENTS ARE STUDENTS BECOME
EMPLOYEES AT VINEYARDS AND
WINERIES AROUND THE STATE.
AND WE ALSO VIRTUALLY BECOME
VINEYARD OWNERS AND WINERY
OWNERS AROUND THE STATE AND ADD
TO THE HUGE ECONOMIC IMPACT.
WITH ONE STREET HAS ON ON
CALIFORNIA AND ON THE COUNTRY.
THE THIRD PART OF THIRD CORE
MISSION THAT WE HAVE IS
EXTENSION AND THAT'S THE IDEA OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION -- IF WE
JUST DO RESEARCH AND WE DON'T
TELL ANYBODY ABOUT IT DOESN'T
REALLY DO ANYBODY ANY GOOD SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE REALLY
FOCUS ON IS HOW TO GET THIS
INFORMATION. TO STAKEHOLDERS
THAT NEED.
AND SO WE HAVE A DEDICATED TEAM
THAT DOES THAT WE RUN ABOUT
FIFTEEN OR MAYBE MORE --
CONTINUE EDUCATION PROGRAMS A
YEAR -- THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
SCEPTRE HARVEST WE KNOW NOBODY'S
GONNA GO -- AND ABOUT TWO THIRDS
OF THOSE AROUND CAMPUS AND ONE
THIRD WE TRAVEL AROUND THE STATE
TO THE MAIN GROWING REGIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE REACHING
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO NEED THAT
INFORMATION THE STATE.
THIS IS SPECIALLY IMPORTANT --
TO NOW IS -- THERE'S SOME
TRANSITION AND UC ANR AND THE I.
IN THERE ARE SOME KEY -- SOME
KEY -- GROWING AREAS IN THE
STATE THE HAVE HAD RETIREMENTS
OF THE FOREMAN VISORS IN THOSE
FORMER VISORS HAVE NOT YET BEEN
REPLACED SINCE NOT CLEAR WHEN OR
IF THEY WILL BE.
IT IS A KEY ISSUE THAT I THINK
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED -- BECAUSE
THAT IS A KEY PART OF THE
EXTENSION TO TURN CONTINUING THE
CUSTOMER FACULTY.
THROUGH -- THROUGH OUR CORPORATE
EXTENSION SPECIALIST TO FARM
ADVISORS IN THE STATE.
ARE WE ALSO HAVE GREAT
FACILITIES -- THIS IS A PICTURE
OF OUR TEACHING RESEARCH WINERY
I KNOW SOME OF YOU HAVE SEEN
MAYBE ALL THE CERTAINLY INVITE
YOU TO COME IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
IT.
IT'S THE MOST ADVANCED THE MOST
SUSTAINABLE WINERY IN THE WORLD --
INTEL RECENTLY WAS THE ONLY LEED
PLATINUM CERTIFIED ONE OR THE
WORLD TO KNOW -- SILVER OKAY HAS
TWO ONE IN OAKVILLE AND THE ONE
HERE IN SONOMA -- VERY PROUD
THAT THEIR PARTNERS WITH JOSH
AND HAVE MUCH SCOTIANS WITH US --
ENTER WELL AS THEY'VE BEEN
DESIGNING THEIR FACILITIES.
I THINK THAT'S GREAT.
I SHOULD MENTION AT THIS
FACILITY BETWEEN THE BUILDING
AND THE EQUIPMENT WAS ABOUT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS --
PRIVATELY FUNDED THERE WAS NO
STATE MONEY PUT INTO THE M. OPEN
UP ONE OTHER KEY FACILITY ONE
TALK ABOUT IS THAT -- FOLKS FOR
MENTAL STATION.
AND FILL IN NAPA VALLEY -- THIS
IS A THERE ARE VERY FEW -- FIFTY
UNIVERSITIES AROUND THE WORLD
WHO HAVE.
VINEYARDS IN REALLY KEY GROWING
REGIONS SO WE'RE VERY LUCKY TO
HAVE HAD THIS SINCE -- ABOUT --
NINETEEN FIFTY N..
REALLY IMPORTANT KNOWLEDGE IS
COMING OUT OF THERE FROM --
PERMITS AND WE NOW HAVE A PROPER
EXTENSION SPECIALIST CONFERRAL
WHO STATION.
SO WITH THAT I JUST LIKE TO
CONCLUDE BY SAYING THAT I THINK
THERE'S IT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT
THAT THE TOP GROWING REGIONS --
PRODUCING REGIONS OF THE WORLD.
ALSO HAVE SOME OF THE TOP
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS IN THE
WORLD SUPPORTING THEM AND
APPRECIATE.
OF ALL THE SUPPORT THAT WE GET
FROM INDUSTRY AND FROM THE STATE --
M. M. CERTAINLY -- WE HOPE THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE A STRONG
PROGRAM THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M NOW ALL
HAVE CLEAR HOW DIFFERENT CFO
FROM MONDAY NGUYEN FAMILY
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TODAY.
I AM PROUD TO BE ABLE TO BRAG A
BIT ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE ON THE
EXECUTIVE MBA COURSE -- WHICH I
STARTED IN MARCH OF SEVENTEEN
AND GRADUATED LAST AUGUST -- SO
AS YOU CAN PROBABLY TELL I'M NOT
FROM THIS REGION AND WHEN I
ARRIVED INTO THE U. S. I WAS
FEELING PRETTY CHUFFED WITH
MYSELF.
I HAD TWENTY YEARS OF FINANCE
EXPERIENCE.
I WAS FROM -- PWC BACKGROUND --
TRANSFERRED TO NEW ZEALAND FROM
THE U. K. WITH THEM.
AND THEN MOVED INTO A VARIETY OF
COMMERCIAL ROLES.
LASTLY IN NEW ZEALAND -- FOR
TREASURY WINE ESTATES IN OAKLAND.
I TRANSFERRED WITH THEM SO THAT
ADDED TO MY RANGE OF
INTERNATIONAL EXPERIENCE IN THE
U. K. AFRICA.
NEW ZEALAND AUSTRALIA -- AND I
HAD BEEN WORKING AT A SENIOR
EXECUTIVE LEVEL FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS INCLUDING BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR TREASURY WINE
ESTATES IN NEW ZEALAND.
BUT WHAT I FOUND WAS THAT I WAS
REALLY PLATEAUED AT A CONTROLLER
SLASH.
FINANCE DIRECTOR LEVEL AND WHEN
I WAS APPLYING FOR ROLES IT
SEEMS THAT.
I WAS EQUIVALENT IN MANY WAYS
APART FROM THE LACK OF A ANDY A
PROGRAM.
SO I DECIDED THAT'S WHAT I
WANTED TO DO -- ADD A FEATHER TO
MY CAT.
AND AS SOON AS I WAS INTRODUCED
TO THE EXECUTIVE WINE MBA
PROGRAM AT CINEMA STATE MY
SEARCH BASICALLY FINISHED.
I KNEW THAT WIND WAS THE CAREER
THAT I'VE BEEN SEARCHING.
FOR I WANTED -- TO GAIN
KNOWLEDGE AND MY BOTH OF MY OWN.
REALM OF FINANCE BUT ALSO HAVE
EXPOSURE TO OTHER COHORT MEMBERS
FROM A WIDE RANGE OF CAREERS --
AND HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT -- I WAS LOOKING FOR
PERSONAL GROWTH AND NETWORKING
NOT NEXT WORKING JUST WITH MY
COHORT MEMBERS BUT ALSO WITH THE
FACULTY.
AND AND AT JOHN PROFESSES -- AND
I'D PROBABLY BE REMISS IF I
WASN'T TO SAY THAT I REALLY JUST
WANT TO THAT CERTIFICATE ALSO --
TO LATE LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
AND FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WOULD COME ABOUT.
SO WHY ONE NBA -- CINEMA STATE
REALLY HAD FOR ME A POINT OF
DIFFERENTIATION -- BEING THE
BUSINESS OF WINE I KNEW THAT
THIS BUILDING WAS GOING TO BE
COMPLETED IN MY TIME HERE.
AND WAS LOOKING FOR TO THAT WAS
A LITTLE BIT LATER THAN I'D
HOPED I I DID SPEND MY LAST
SEMESTER -- IN THIS BUILDING AND
GRADUATED IN THIS ROOM -- I WAS
DEFINITELY OFFERED TO WERE
NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES -- AT
EVERY LEVEL WITH THE FACULTY
HERE -- WITH THE JOHN PROFESSES
WITH MY MY UNKNOWN COHORT -- SO
I REALLY FELT THAT I HAD A GREAT.
A NETWORK OF FUTURE LEADERS IN
THE WINE INDUSTRY -- AND I WE
LEFT.
FEELING LIKE I HAD A GREATER --
POSSIBILITY OF ACHIEVING MY CFO
ENVISION -- SO ACTUALLY WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF COMPLETELY
PROGRAM I HAD TO SEE IF --
OFFICE -- SO IT WAS A SEISMIC
SHIFT FOR ME AND I AND HE ENDED
MASSIVE -- SO I AM NOW THE CFO
OF SEMEN W. FAMILY WHICH
INCLUDES A CHILD PROOF AND C.
CAME ON W. -- THROUGH THAT I
ALSO BECAME DIRECT -- TO ON THE
BOARD OF APPELLATION SAINT
HELENA SO I REALLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO APPLY IN A VERY PRACTICAL WAY
MY LEARNINGS -- THROUGH OUR
STRATEGIC PROGRAM. TO BETTER THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR ONE TO ME
ONE REMEMBERS AND CONSUMERS -- I
I HAD AN IMMEDIATE IMPROVEMENT
IN MY STOCK MANAGEMENT AS WE AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM EVERYBODY LABOR
IS SO CONSTRICTED THAT TO JUST.
TURN THE DIAL IN THE SLIGHTEST
WAY MAKES A MASSIVE IMPROVEMENT --
TO RETAINING STUFF.
I'VE MADE LIFELONG FRIEND
FRIENDSHIPS AND CONNECTIONS
WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM I WOULD
NEVER HAVE HEARD ABOUT MY
OPPORTUNITY IT WAS -- ON THE
QUIET -- I WAS PUT ON TO IT BY
ONE OF MY COHORT MEMBERS SO HE
REALLY HAD A DIRECT.
IMPACT ON MY CAREER -- I'VE HAD
UNPARALLELED EXPOSURE TO SENIOR
LEADERS IN THE WINE INDUSTRY
BOTH AT FACULTY LEVEL -- THROUGH
LECTURES COMING -- FROM AT THAT
BOTH PRESSES AND OTHER INDUSTRY
EXECUTIVES -- AND IT REALLY HAS
CEMENTED MY COMMITMENT TO MY
INDUSTRY -- THERE THERE'S PEOPLE
WHO COME AROUND FROM CANNABIS
AND SAY HEY YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
ABOUT ONE AND COME OVER TO OUR
SIDE.
NO THIS IS -- I I REALLY AT THAT
THROUGH BEING ONE OF ONE AND A
HALF PEOPLE WITH FINANCE ON MY
COHORT.
EVERYBODY ELSE IS FROM A
DIFFERENT -- THAT SKILL SET TO
MINE SO IT REALLY JUST MENTIONED
MY WHY THE KNOWLEDGE OF OUR
INDUSTRY -- SO AGAIN THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU TO RAY -- I I KNOW
THAT WE WE MARCH ARM IN ARM ON
OUR COMMITMENT TO THIS AND I WAS
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M FEELING LIKE I DON'T KNOW
ENOUGH.
WHICH IS THE NEXT WE HAVE
SHANNON WALKER HIGH THE STATE
MANAGER HIDE THE STATE WINERY.
HI THANK YOU. FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY I APPRECIATE IT -- JUST TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BACKGROUND
ABOUT ME I GREW UP ON THE EAST
COAST AT JUST RIGHT OUTSIDE OF
NEW YORK CITY.
I GREW UP IN A HOME THAT WAS
WELL VERSED IN WINE MY
GRANDFATHER AND MY FATHER BOTH
SO I LEARNED ABOUT ONE OF THE
YOUNG AGE I RECEIVED AN
UNDERGRAD IN BROADCAST
JOURNALISM AND SHORTLY AFTER
LANDED A JOB AND TV NETWORKS AS
THE ASSISTANT TO THE SP PF
PRODUCTION.
OVER THE NEXT SIX YEARS I CLIMB
MY WAY UP TO LINE PRODUCER OF ON
AIR PROMOS FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT
GROUP OF AND TV NETWORKS.
AND WHAT I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
MYSELF AND I HAD A LOT OF FUN
DOING IT I WORK TWENTY TWO HOUR
DAYS SEVEN DAYS A WEEK I TRAVEL
CONSISTENTLY.
I STARTED TO HATE MY LIFE PATH.
EXCEPT FOR THE SMALL AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT I BEGAN TAKING
INTEREST IN MY LONG TIME FAMILY
HOBBY OF WINE MAKING.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY
TRANSITION INTO THE WINE
INDUSTRY IN TWENTY ELEVEN I MADE
MY FIRST VINTAGE OF MEL BACK
WITH MY FATHER WITH GRACE FROM A
COMPANY CALLED MUSTER ONE GREAT
COMPANY.
AND I ABSOLUTELY FELL IN LOVE.
NOW THAT'S GREAT COMPANY TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEM THEY ARE
A COMPANY THAT PURCHASED GRAPES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN SHIP THEM BACK ON A
TRUCK TO THE EAST COAST EITHER
IN JUICE OR GREAT FORM. FOR
CUSTOMERS LIKE ME TO PURCHASE I
MAKE HOMEMADE WINE IT'S A VERY
INTERESTING BUSINESS MODEL AT
THE VERY SUCCESSFUL IN -- MODEL
AT THIS COMPANY PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN MY
TRANSITION BECAUSE OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS I BEGAN TO GET TO KNOW
CHRISTINA MOSCOW.
WHO IS NOW THE OWNER AND MANAGER
OF MUSTER ONE GREAT COMPANY AND
SHE HAPPENED TO BE IN THE FIRST
COHORT OF THIS PROGRAM?
SO SHE TOLD ME ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM SHE TOLD ME THAT SHE
LOVED IT AND SHE CONVINCED ME TO
CHANGE MY CAREER.
SO I DID.
I APPLIED I GOT IN I WAS
ACCEPTED I DROVE CROSS COUNTRY
QUIT MY JOB AND LANDED HERE AND
STARTED OVER.
DURING THE PROGRAM A CLASSMATE'S
WIFE HIRED ME OVER INGLENOOK
WINERY AND I BEGAN TO LEARN ALL
THE INNER WORKINGS OF THE SALES
AND MARKETING FOR THIS INDUSTRY.
BY THE END OF THE PROGRAM I WAS
COMPLETELY INFATUATED AND I DID
NOT WANT TO LEAVE NOW.
THE BEING THE PERSON THAT I AM I
KNEW I NEEDED A BIGGER CHALLENGE
SO I ENDED UP LANDING A JOB FREE
FLOW WINES AFTER MEETING THE
OWNER JORDAN CABLE STAT DURING
ONE OF OUR CLASSES WHEN HE WAS A
GUEST SPEAKER.
I SPENT THE NEXT TWO AND A HALF
YEARS GROWING MY MARKETING AND
SALES EXPERIENCE UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE HYDE
FAMILY ASKED ME IF I WOULD COME
WORK FOR THEM AND THAT'S WHEN I
BEGAN MY NEXT CHAPTER.
WHICH IS WORKING AT HYDE ESTATE
WINERY IN CARNEROS.
IT'S A NEW WINERY THAT OPENED UP
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND I'M
CURRENTLY OVERSEEN THE STRATEGIC
VISION OF THE TTC AND WHOLESALE
CHANNELS.
WE PRODUCE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED CASES ITS SINGLE LOCKING
ANWAR CHARDONNAY AMARILLO WE DO
A FEW SMALLER VARIETALS LIKES TO
ROTH AND FEELING AS WELL.
IT'S UP ESTE GROWN PRODUCED AND
BOTTLED FROM A SECTION OF HIDE
VINEYARDS WHICH THE VINEYARD IN
THE VALLEY THAT'S BEEN.
SELLING GRAPES EXCLUSIVELY TO
LEAK WINERY PRODUCERS FOR FORTY
YEARS.
SINCE I'VE COME ON BOARD I
SUCCESSFULLY HELP THE FAMILY
GROW THE TASTING ROOM TRAFFIC BY
30% THE TTC BY 60% AND THEIR
WHOLESALE BY 15%.
WHICH WHAT I CONSIDER IS A
REALLY GOOD TRAJECTORY FOR WHERE
WE'RE GONNA BE AS WE CONTINUE TO
GROW IN JUST YEAR TWO OF THE
TASTING ROOM.
SO TO GET REALLY TO THE KNEE OF
MY SPEECH HERE -- WHEN I WAS
THINKING ABOUT WHAT THIS PROGRAM
IS DONE FOR ME AT FIVE POINTS
CAME TO MY MIND OBVIOUSLY THE
CAREER CHANGE? FOR SOMEONE LIKE
ME THIS PROGRAM REALLY HELP ME
LAUNCH INTO THE WINE BUSINESS
AND ENHANCE MY EDUCATION BY
GIVING THE TOOLS TO SUCCEED IN
THIS BUSINESS THEY PROVIDE A
PRACTICAL APPLICATION.
AND A SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE OF
THE INDUSTRY.
IT HAD FANTASTIC NETWORKING
ASSETS YOU NOT ONLY PROVIDED ME
WITH A GROUP OF WINE BUSINESS
SAVVY PEOPLE TO UTILIZE BUT
PROVIDED ME WITH A NETWORK OF
PEOPLE TO GET TO KNOW SINCE I
WAS NEW TO THE AREA.
IT PROVIDED HIGHER EARNING
POTENTIAL AND I KNOW THAT MOST
I. MASTERS PROGRAM PROVIDE THIS
ESPECIALLY WITH MY SPECIALTY WE
SEE USUALLY AT 38% INCREASE IN
PAY.
BUT JUST FOR THE FUN OF IT I
SPOKE TO THE COHORT LAST WEEK
AND 95% OF THEM HAVE SAID BABY
THERE SEEN A PAY INCREASE WERE
THEY PLANTED THEIR DREAM JOB IN
THE FOUR YEARS THAT WE'VE
GRADUATED.
AND FINALLY I CAN'T LEAVE IT OUT
AS RAY POINTED TO THE TRAVEL YOU
CAN DO AN INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL.
SO YOU COULD TAKE EVERYTHING
YOU'VE APPLIED AND GO SEE -- YOU
KNOW SOMETHING FUN A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AT A VERY STRESSFUL
TIME IN YOUR LIFE -- OVERALL
THIS PROGRAM REALLY GAVE ME THE
TOOLS TO SUCCESSFULLY LAUNCH MY
NEW CAREER PATH.
AND I COULD NOT BE DOING WHAT
I'M CURRENTLY DOING AS
CONFIDENTLY AS IN DOING IT IF I
HADN'T GRADUATED FROM THEM SO
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON -- CHAIR AND WE ARE
CURRY.
SHARES MCGUIRE AND DODD.
RATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I AM
TONY STEVEN MY DAY JOB AND SHE
SELLS OFFICER FOR SHIED FAMILY
WINES IN MONTEREY CALIFORNIA --
MID SIZE WINERY INFORM CONCERN.
I'M ALSO CHAIRPERSON OF THE
AMERICAN WIENER FOUNDATION.
AND THE NATIONAL GREAT RESEARCH
ALLIANCE. TWO ORGANIZATIONS
FOCUSED ON FUNDING RESEARCH IN
THE WINE INDUSTRY -- IT'S BEEN
DOING THAT FOR QUITE A WHILE I
FEEL LIKE IT.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
INDUSTRY.
IT'S THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF IT --
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO GET TO
REALLY ASK FOR A FOCUS ON
RESEARCH FUNDING FOR INDUSTRY.
I BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE DRESSED CAN
BE SOLVED THROUGH THE RESEARCHER
ADVANCE OF RESEARCH --
CALIFORNIA HAS A PLACE IN THE
GLOBALLY.
AS ONE OF THE HIGHEST QUALITY
PRODUCERS.
IN THE WORLD WERE ALSO THE US IS
ALSO THE PLACE TO MARKET WINE.
AND OUR INDUSTRY GOES UP AGAINST
SOVEREIGN FUNDS THAT FUND
RESEARCH AND MARKETING EFFORTS --
BOTH IN THOSE COUNTRIES AND
MARKET EFFORTS IN THE US SO
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPETITION OUT
THERE.
AND WE SEE IT DIRECTLY.
AND IF YOU GET THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GO TO AN EVENT LIKE PRO LINE
YOU'LL SEE OUR PLACE.
IN THE WINE INDUSTRY IS.
IS NOT THIS IS NOT LARGE.
IN TERMS OF CALIFORNIA IS -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE SITTING HERE IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL FACILITY.
GORGEOUS DAY I FEEL LIKE OUR
INDUSTRY.
HAS COME VERY FAR I'M A PRODUCT
OF THE CLASS SIZE WITH A CULTURE
PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS.
I FARMED FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
GRAPES.
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HERE.
AND OF WE HAVE MOVED INTO -- THE
TECHNICAL SIDE AND ALSO THE
SALES SIDE OF THE WIND.
SO I WANTED TO TALK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT -- TWO HIGHLIGHT TWO KEY
INNOVATION TRANS THAT I FEEL
LIKE OUR OPPORTUNITIES AND MAYBE
EVEN.
OUR OBLIGATION -- TO INCREASE
RESEARCH FUNDING FOR I'M THE
FIRST ONE IS THE ADVANCE.
THE GREAT ADVANCEMENTS IN
GENETIC RESEARCH -- TECHNIQUES
THAT HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED -- FOR
THE HUMAN GENOME ARE BEING MOVED
INTO -- UNLOCKING THE GENOME OF
NOT ONLY GRAPEVINES AND
CULTIVARS.
BUT ALSO GREAT FUN PEST AND
DISEASES AND I BELIEVE THAT'S
WHERE THE PROBLEM LIES.
AND CONTROL WHEN MAKING MORE
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE OUR
VINEYARDS BY WORKING ON THE
HOUSE -- THERE THE WE'RE JUST
BEGINNING TO APPLY THESE NEW
TECHNIQUES. TO SOLVE MAJOR
CHALLENGES -- AND THERE IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
REDUCE OR EVEN ELIMINATE THE USE
OF PESTICIDES BASED ON THE
UNDERSTANDING OF GENETICS ABOUT
THE THE THE VINES AND THE IN THE
PAST.
THE OTHER AREA IS IT IS ONE
WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH.
AND AND THAT IS -- THE USE OF
DATA.
AND USE IT EVERY DAY ON YOUR
PHONE BUT BUT IN OUR UNIVERSE
IT'S PRECISION FARMING.
AND PRECISION FARMING -- IS A
TERM THAT'S USED TO AND THAT'S
IT'S BEEN TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF AND
GRAIN CROPS.
CROPS ARE PLANTED EVERY YEAR.
IT'S A LOT HARDER AND PERENNIAL
CROPS ONES WITH A PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT STAY UP YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
YOUR THREE YEAR -- SO WHAT IT
REALLY MEANS IS RIGHT NOW WE
MANAGE OUR VINEYARD BLOCKS AND
IN.
BASICALLY TWENTY ACRE BLOCKS
WHATEVER SIZE THE BLOCK IS
SOMETIMES MORE SOMETIMES LARGER.
WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY NOW TO
COLLECT DATA AT THE VINE LEVEL
FIVE LINE SO FOR EXAMPLE AND AT
SIDE WHEN YOU'RE.
WE KNOW THE YIELD OFF OF EVERY
VINE BY USING.
RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD
TECHNOLOGY THAT HUESO FRUIT
COMING OFF.
I CAN BEAR WHEN THE VINE IS
HARVESTED.
AND WE USE THAT IS OUR REPORT
CARD FOR ALL THE INPUTS WE DID
DURING THE YEAR.
AND I I WANT TO JUST KIND OF
GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF WHAT THIS
PROMISES -- WE USE THAT AS ONE
PIECE OF DATA AND THEN
EVERYTHING WE PUT IN.
WE USE IS -- OTHER LAYERS OF
DATA FROM STUFF THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE MUCH WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE SOIL.
BUT THERE'S THE LABOR AND PARTS --
WE NOW HAVE MACHINES THAT WILL
TAKE THAT INFORMATION AND
WITHOUT.
INDIVIDUAL MANAGEMENT BUT JUST
WHAT THEY DO TO THE VINE.
WHETHER THEY'RE SPRAYING OR OR
LEAVE BURYING OUR SHOOT SENDING.
THAT'S PRECISION FARMING AND AND
IF WE CAN GET A 10% INCREASE.
IN YIELD AND I AND OR JUST IN
THE TYPE OF FRUIT WE WANT.
IF WE CAN TAKE A LOW YIELDING
VINES AND RAISE THEM UP THE
HIGHLIGHT YIELDING VINES AND
BRING THEM DOWN.
THAT'S 10% ON IT ON IT CHRIS
LIKE SHY THAT'S FOUR HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL ACRES THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO PLANT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO SPRAY.
FERTILIZE WATER WHICH JUST DOING
BETTER HONOR JUST INFORMING AND
THAT'S NOT.
THE FANTASY THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW.
JUST IN DIFFERENT STAGES.
RIGHT NOW ONLY THE BIGGER
COMPANIES -- GALLO'S STRIDE
COMPANIES THAT ARE INNOVATIVE
AND AND INVEST IN RESEARCH CAN
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
BY FINDING THAT -- DIRECTLY BY
FINDING DR BLOCKS PROGRAMS AND
OTHER PROGRAMS AROUND -- THE
STATE WE CAN BRING THAT TO EVERY
FARMER THOSE CHALLENGES ARE REAL --
OUR LABOR COSTS.
THE COST OF FARM INVENTOR FROM
WHEN I STARTED INSIDE AND NOW IS
UP 50%.
BASICALLY FROM FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS AN ACRE.
TO SIX THOUSAND THE THE LABOR
COSTS JUST MANDATED LABOR RATES.
ARE GOING TO CREATE A 40%
INCREASE BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
I'M JUST A DIRECT COST OF LABOR --
THE OTHER PART IS OUR LABOR
FORCES EIJI.
AND AND THERE'S WE WOULD NEED TO
BRING NEW PEOPLE AND THESE
PEOPLE NEED TO BE ABLE TO USE A
LAPTOP.
AND EVERY MACHINE WE HAVE NOW
HAS A COMPUTER AND SO SO WITH
THAT YOU CAN I GET THE PICTURE
RIGHT THERE'S LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITY OUT THERE -- IT'S
NOT SCIENCE FICTION IT'S REAL
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING AND
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO TO YOU
KNOW.
BUILD A BETTER SYSTEM FAR MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY -- HAVE
OUR PRODUCTS THAT ADAPT TO A
CHANGING CLIMATE [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH AND QUALITY RESEARCH CAN
ONLY BE ACHIEVED WITH CONSISTENT
AND RELIABLE FUNDING.
AND THE ATF HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
FORTY YEARS SELF FUNDING.
RESEARCH -- DRIVEN BY INDUSTRY
VOLUNTEER.
FALLING TEARS IT FROM THE
RESEARCH WHY IT GOT LINES
BECAUSE AFTER FEDERAL FUNDS --
AT THE END I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF CARPET THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS.
AND YOU HAVE A WHITE PAPER THAT
DESCRIBES -- POTENTIAL FUNDING
FOR AND TALENT AND PUBLIC
PRIVATE FUNDED AND DOMINANT THE
VALUE OF AN INDICTMENT IS THAT.
THIS IS WHAT RESEARCHERS THE YOU
CAN'T GET IT ALL DONE IN ONE
FUNDING CYCLE IN ONE YEAR THIS
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND AND THAT'S
THE STABILITY THAT THE AMERICAN
I'VE SEEN OF AMERICA VINEYARD
FOUNDATION.
WE RELIABLY FUN YOU'RE AFTER
HERE WE CAN FIND MULTI YOUR
PROJECTS AND A GENTLEMAN OF THE
TYPE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
GENERATES THE SAME FINDS YOUR
AFTER YEAR.
AND WILL BE IT WILL ATTRACT
RESEARCHERS WITH BIGGER PROJECTS
AND MORE IMPORTANT PROJECTS SO.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THAT AND YOU'RE
LOOKING AT IT.
AND I THINK I WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO IMPROVING OUR ABILITY OKAY
CALIFORNIA'S GLOBAL LEADERSHIP.
AND WIDEN VITICULTURE.
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING.
WHAT THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY -- TRULY
APPRECIATE IT I I DO WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON YOUR LAST
COMMENTS A MISTER STEVEN -- I
LIVE AS WELL AS USE TODAY'S I
LIVE RIGHT BY THE RESEARCH
CENTER FOR THE GRAPES AND THEY
HAVE THE LIBRARY THERE.
AND I WAS JUST THERE FOR W. LOOK
A DINNER THE OTHER DAY FOR THE
WINNERS FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM
AND THEN THE SPENT TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE ON A LONG TABLE.
AND WE HAD A INCREDIBLE --
EDUCATION THAT DAY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS LIBRARY THEY
HAVE THEIR AND THE YEAR BEFORE
THEY SAID THEY WERE THE NUMBER
ONE LIBRARY.
THEY SAID THEY'VE NOW OR NUMBER
TWO AND I WAS JUST CURIOUS HOW
DO YOU GO TO NUMBER.
TWO BUT I WAS YOU KNOW CURIOUS
LIKE HOW DID THAT HAPPEN WAS IT.
I'M JUST NEW BREEDS ARE -- TYPES
OF ROOTS DOCTOR COMING OUT NOW
OR AS A YOU KNOW.
WHY WORRY ABOUT?
ALL THE GREAT ALL THE GREAT BREW
US DOCTORS OUT THERE I THINK
EVERY SINGLE -- GRAPES IT'S EVER
BEEN GROWN IS OUT AT THAT WE'LL
SKILL RANCH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
I'M NOT SURE HOW THOSE THINGS --
RANKED -- BUT CERTAINLY THAT
KIND OF POSITIVE WORRY FOR PLANT
MATERIALS ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL SO
YOU KNOW WITH WHICH HI
FOUNDATION SERVICES OR ANDY
WALKERS BREEDING PROGRAM IN OUR
DEPARTMENT -- THOSE KIND OF
RESOURCES -- REALLY EXPENSIVE
BUT ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
COMING UP WITH.
PLANT MATERIAL THAT'S THAT WILL
LEAD TO DISEASE RESISTANCE OR
DROUGHT TOLERANCE OR SMALL
TOLERANCE OR ANY OTHER THINGS WE
NEED.
I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY HOW THAT'S
THAT'S RIGHT.
SO I JUST WANTED TO GIVE A SHOUT
OUT ON THAT NOTE TO UC DAVIS
WHEN.
I WAS ON MY PROGRAM WE WENT TO
CROATIA AND WE VISITED THE
UNIVERSITY OF RABIN.
AND THEY HAD -- TO WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH UC DAVIS TO
IDENTIFY THE GENEALOGY OF
TRINIDAD.
AND SO I I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY --
PROUD MOMENT FOR US TO BE IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT COUNTRY AND
TO HAVE SUCH RECOGNITION SO IT
REALLY IS GLOBALLY RECOGNIZED
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
WELL DONE.
AND THE GENETIC I THE GENETIC
RESEARCH I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ON
I THINK THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE THAT WE SHOULD
BE.
FUNDING THAT KIND OF RESEARCH --
WE'VE DONE -- WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT PAST -- AND DISEASE.
WE FOUND OUT THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT -- CALIFORNIA PART OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION THAT WE HAD
REQUESTED THEM TO DO SOME NEW
BIO DIVERSITY TYPE THINGS WITH --
PAST.
AS I HELPED GET THE FUNDED.
AND FOUND OUT.
THEY HADN'T DONE ONE THING WITH
IT.
SO WE'VE BEEN SENSE AND HAD THEM
IN OUR OFFICE TO SAY WHAT
HAPPENED TO THOSE PEOPLE WERE
WORKING ON SPECIFICALLY ON
TRYING TO REDUCE THE USE OF
PESTICIDES.
HERBICIDES ETCETERA AND SO I
WHAT YOU CAN BE ASSURED THAT WE
ARE KEEPING AN EYE ON IT BECAUSE
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REDUCE.
OF THOSE TYPES OF A OF CHEMICALS
OF FOUR CROPS.
AND LASTLY IT'S BEEN AMAZING IN
THE SHORT TIME THAT I'VE BEEN IN
THE LEGISLATURES OF THE TRAINING
MY OTHER COLLEAGUES FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT.
IT TAKES TO BE A FARMER.
AND SO ARE YOU YOU -- HIT A
NERVE WITH ME WHICH IS A GOOD
NERVOUS JUST SAYING PRECISION
FARMING -- ROOTS WHAT I TELL
PEOPLE BATES TO STILL SHOW UP IN
THE BOTTLES THEY DON'T JUST SHOW
UP IN THE GROCERY STORE -- BUT
IT STARTS FROM THE HEALTHY SOIL
TO THE ROOT STOCK TO MAKING SURE
THAT YOU ARE NURTURING THAT
PLANT ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
ITS LIFE SO -- THEY'RE STARTING
TO UNDERSTAND IT WE'RE TAKING
THEM ON TOURS AND HOPEFULLY THE
SOME OF THESE THINGS THAT WE
REQUEST -- GOING FOR A FORWARD
WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET SOME
FUNDING FOR SOME OF THOSE AS
LONG AS WE EDUCATE SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE NOT
UNDERSTANDING OF AGRICULTURE
IT'S REALLY.
IMPORTANT WE DO SO SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
IN COMMON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BEN CHAIR
WONDERFUL JOB EACH VIEW THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY.
I MISS JOHNSON TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT ON THE ISSUE OF
RESEARCH IN WHERE YOU'D LIKE TO
GO OBVIOUSLY.
THERE'S ALWAYS GONNA BE A FINE
CAN JUST GIVE US A LITTLE BIT OF
A DEEPER DIVE.
INTO SOME OF THE WEAKNESSES THAT
WE NEED WIENER SHORE UP WITH
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH WHICH WOULD
IMPROVISE WITH DATA.
YES.
SO FIRST OFF THE DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS IS A PROJECT --
THAT THE FACULTY WILL PRESENT
THE FIRST SLICE OF ON JULY TENTH.
SO -- IF ONE OF YOUR STAFF --
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO COME BACK
TO CAMPUS -- WE WELCOME THAT YOU
GET A LOOK AT THAT FIRST HAND --
ALSO THAT THEY WILL BE
PRESENTING SOME PREVIEWS OF SOME
LONGER RESEARCH PROJECTS THAT
PEOPLE ARE DEVELOPING.
IN PARTICULAR ON THE Z.
GENERATION AND THEIR INTEREST --
OR LESS INTEREST IN WINE AND
WHERE THAT LOOKS LIKE IT MIGHT
DEVELOP -- RIGHT NOW IS IT'S A
IT'S A I CHALLENGE THE INDUSTRY
WANTS TO GET AHEAD RIGHT.
SO IT'S A VERY COMPETITIVE
MARKET -- TONY HAD TALKED ABOUT --
THE FUNDING THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
IN OTHER COUNTRIES FOR THEIR
WORK SO THEN NOT ONLY FOR
RESEARCH IN -- PLANT PRODUCTION
AND WINEMAKING BUT ALSO IN THE
MARKETING AND IT REALLY IS
ASTOUNDING THE MARKETING DOLLARS
THAT ARE PUT FORWARD BY OTHER
COUNTRIES.
SO WE'RE WORKING ON PROJECTS TO
HELP BETTER IDENTIFY HOW TO
REACH OUR TARGET CONSUMERS.
AND THEN THE THIRD ONE IN THAT
REALM IS WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
CONSUMERS -- THE LIFEBLOOD FOR
MANY WINERIES WHEN YOU -- JANET
GAVE YOU SOME -- SOME STATISTICS
ON HOW THEIR SALES BREAK DOWN BY
CHANNEL IN THE DIRECT TO
CONSUMER CHANNEL HAS BECOME A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE AND GETTING
THAT RIGHT WHAT WE FIND IS
CONSUMERS NOT ONLY OF OLDER
SEGMENTS BUT IN PARTICULAR OF
YOUNGER SEGMENTS.
ARE LOOKING FOR AN EXPERIENCE
WHEN THEY COME TO A WINERY AND
SO HELPING OUR WINERIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BECOME MORE
COMPETITIVE AND ATTRACT MORE
CONSUMERS TO HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE IS IS REALLY VITAL.
YEAH YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT INTO
IF YOU ALL DON'T MIND AND THEN
AT THE TOP OF SMOKE TEEN ISSUES
WELL.
WHAT IS IN REGARDS TO THE TO THE
EXPERIENCE SERVICES THEY'RE
GONNA?
ENHANCE -- DESIRE FOR FOOD
PAIRINGS RIGHT SIR COMING TO THE
TASTING ROOM -- HAVING TO BE
ABLE TO PACKAGE THIS WITH
OVERSEAS TO WALK US THROUGH IF
YOU LOOK OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
BIGGEST CHANGE WE THINK WE'RE
GOING IN REGARD TO THAT
EXPERIENCE.
AND IT ALSO TALK WITH ABOUT
LOYALTY.
ARE YOU SEEING FOLKS STUCK WITH
ONE BRAND.
ARE YOU SEEING FOLKS DOING --
PRICE TAG SHOP IN WHAT IS THAT.
I THAT YOU SEEN ACROSS THE BOARD.
THAT'S A PRETTY LOADED QUESTION.
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT MARKET YOU'RE
REALLY LOOKING FOR SPECIFICALLY
AT HIGH TO STAY WHERE A SMALL
BOUTIQUE FAMILY OWNED FAMILY RUN
WINERY.
SO THAT'S TYPE OF THAT CUSTOMERS
THAT WE'RE GETTING WE'RE NOT
DOING FOOD PAIRINGS WORD NOT
HAVING LARGE TOWARDS OR NOT JEAN
BACHELORETTES WE'RE TRYING TO
GET ONE I. ONE VERY FOCUSED
EDUCATIONAL WITH.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE VINEYARD
AND HOW THAT'S SHOWCASING IN THE
CLASS OF ONE THIRTY STEVEN?
SO THAT'S OUR EXPERIENCE NOT THE
CLIENTELE WERE GETTING WHEN IT
COMES TO LOYALTY ONCE THEY
BECOME A MEMBER OF OURS AND
THEY'RE USUALLY.
I WOULD HOPE FOR A LONG TIME
WE'VE BEEN OPEN FOR TWO YEARS
BUT WE GET PEOPLE WHO KNOW US
THEY KNOW US BY NAME THEY KNOW
MY FATHER IN LAW MY MOTHER IN
LAW THEY THEY HAVE AN EXPERIENCE
WHERE THEY FEEL LIKE THEIR
FAMILY WITHOUT HER INVESTED.
THEIR INVESTED WITH US AND WHAT
I'M SHOWCASING AND I'VE SEEN IS
THAT I'M GETTING A LOT PEOPLE MY
AGE OR YOUNGER WHO ARE.
COMING UP FROM SAN FRANCISCO
DON'T WANT TO GO ALL THE WAY AT
VALLEY THEY THEY WANT SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR
BOTTLE CAPS THEY'RE ENJOYING A
PIANO AND CHARDONNAY BUT IT A
DECENT PRICE.
SO I THINK IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
EACH WINERY IN EAT WHAT EACH
PERSON LOOKING TO GIVE.
AND WHEN I GIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
THE PEOPLE I ALWAYS SAY WHAT
KIND OF EXPERIENCE WOULD YOU
LIKE IN THE VALLEY BECAUSE WE
CAN OFFER ANYTHING FOR YOU HOW
MUCH SUSTAINABILITY PLAY INTO
THAT LOYALTY YOU.
THEY HOW YOU FARM -- IN WORKING
ON THAT STORY TO BE ABLE TO GET
THAT GREAT INTO THE BOTTLE.
IT'S A MAKE MAJOR DIFFERENCE AND
I DO AT A CUSTOM FREE FLOW WINDS
FOR TEACHING ME SO MUCH ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY BECAUSE AS AN
EAST COASTER.
LET'S FACE IT WE'RE NOT VERY
SUSTAINABLE PEOPLE.
IT IS NOT FOR ME WHEN I
AGRICULTURE WHAT'S DIFFERENT --
SO FOR US IT'S IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW THAT WE ARE ORGANIC THAT WE
DON'T DO A LOT TO THE GRAVE ONCE
IT HITS WE LET SHOWCASE WHAT
IT'S DOING.
AND THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
SO I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO HAVE SUSTAINABILITY WE ARE
NOT A CERTIFIED GREEN WE HAVE
ALL OF OUR SIGNS UP WE MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF IT --
AND WE HAVE A SUSTAINABILITY
PLANNED SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT SENSE THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
FOR SO WE ARE A BELLY.
AND WE DO HAVE A WIDE RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES SO WE WE WORK ON
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT MODELS
SHANNON -- WHICH IS GOOD -- VERY
COMPLIMENTARY -- WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND IN THE PASSING YEARS IS
THAT PEOPLE REALLY ARE
INTERESTED IN TRYING TO HIT?
FIVE OR SIX WINERIES IN ONE DAY
THEY ARE INVESTING MORE OF THEIR
TIME AND THEY DO YOU WANT A MORE
ROUNDED EXPERIENCE -- WHETHER
THAT BE -- MOMENT WITH THE WIND
MAKE -- WHETHER THAT BE AN
ACTIVITY AROUND WINE -- WE ARE
FINDING THAT WE HAVE QUITE A
BLEND OF VERY LOYAL OLDER
CUSTOMERS BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF
MILLENNIALS ARE COMING THROUGH
AND THEY ARE.
MORE TRICKY TO CAPTURE AND AND
KEEP THE OIL I THINK THERE'S A
GREAT DEAL OF A THRIVING FOR
EXPERIMENTATION WITH THAT THAT
SET -- SO WE DO INVEST A LOT OF
TIME IN OUR OWN INTERNAL
RESEARCH ON WHAT RESONATES WITH
THOSE ON THE SETS BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY THEY WILL BECOME OUR
LOYAL ONE CONSUME AS A FUTURE SO --
WE ARE SEVENTY FIVE YEARS OLD
NOW WE'VE WE TAKE PRIDE IN BEING
THE FIRST WINERY BUT WE HAVE TO
STAY NIMBLE AND HAVE TO BE
FLEXIBLE.
AND JUST BE AHEAD OF THE GAME --
GIVEN THE AN IMMENSE AMOUNT OF
COMPETITION.
IN THE QUESTION DESIGNED FOR
SUSTAINABILITY HOW MUCH DOES
THAT PLAY INTO THE MESSAGES WELL
RIGHT AS FAR AS YOUR MISSION.
AND THE OTHER PIECES SO -- ARE
YOU FINDING YOUNGER CONSUMERS
ARE MORE FOCUSED ON WHAT IF IT'S
NOT GONNA BE I'M MAKING THIS UP
ONE OR TWO BRANDS THAT THEY LIKE.
WHAT DO THEY WANT?
I THINK THEY WANT A SENSE OF
ADVENTURE -- AND I THINK THEY
THEY GET THAT FROM HAVING THAT
EXPERIENCE AROUND ONE AND HAVING
THAT MOMENT THAT THEY CAN TAKE
BACK HOME TO SAIL WHEN I WAS A
CHILD COULD I GET THIS -- SO I
THINK IT IS -- IT'S COMBINING
THAT THAT ONE MOMENT AND TAKEN
AT HOME -- SUSTAINABILITY FOR US
WE HAVE A BEAUTIFUL STATE AND SO
WE AUTOMATICALLY BENEFIT FROM
THE FEELING OF SUSTAINABILITY
FOR PEOPLE WHO VISIT THE STATE --
SO IT IT DOES RESONATE -- AS
WELL AS THE TALE OF OF HAVING A
WINERY THAT'S WITHSTOOD THE TEST
OF TIME AND THE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
AND CLIMATE CHALLENGES THAT WE
HAVE SO -- WE'RE WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THE PROSPECT OF BEING ABLE.
TO MAKE MORE OF OUR I STAYED IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
MIKE IF I COULD IS SENATE
REQUIRE IF I COULD ADD -- IN
ADDITION -- TO WHAT CLAIRE.
AND SHANNON SHARED THE THE THIS
ISSUE THAT YOU BRING UP ABOUT
LOYALTY IS IS A CHALLENGING ONE
TO OVERCOME RIGHT.
AND AND HOW DO YOU SOLVE FOR
THAT SO ONE OF THE RESEARCH
PROJECTS WE'VE HAD HAS LOOKED AT
THE DATA THAT JUST EXIST AT THE
WINERY DURING THE WINERY
EXPERIENCE WHAT DO WE LEARN
ABOUT THAT CUSTOMER SO THAT WE
CAN BETTER BE ABLE TO GIVE THAT
BACK WHAT IT.
IS THEY LIVE.
SO THAT THAT'S THAT'S ONE
TRANCHE AND THEN THE SECOND IS --
SUSTAINABILITY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE END WE SEE
PEOPLE STARTING TO FOCUS THEIR
BUYING -- THE SIM CONNIE WINE
GROWERS HAVE DONE SOME REALLY
GOOD STUDIES ON THIS AND OUR
BOARD HAS ASKED US TO HELP.
DEFINE WHAT SUSTAINABILITY MEANS
TO PEOPLE IN THEIR MINDS SO
THAT'S A FUTURE PROJECT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON BECAUSE
IT'S THE DEFINITION IS IS TOUGH
IF YOU ASK TEN PEOPLE YOU MAY
NOT GET YOU WON'T GET THE SAME
ANSWER.
SO WE'D LIKE TO COME UP WITH A
WAY TO BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
THAT THAT WOULD FACILITATE A
GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
GOOD THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY DOING IN THEIR VINEYARDS
AND WINERIES.
SO IT TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABILITY PIECE.
IT COULD TAKE A COUPLE HOURS IF
WE HAD A CONFERENCE LIKE THIS
YEAH SO SO -- SIDE FAMILY WINES.
WE MARKET AROUND THE WORLD
THERE'S SIXTY BRANDS AND WE SELL
OVERSEAS AND AND IF IT IS THE
FIRST QUESTION.
OVER THERE -- SO WE WE HAVE A
TWO MEGAWATT WIND TURBINE 1100%
POWER BY WHEN WE RECYCLE
EVERYTHING -- WATER COMPOST OUR
VINEYARDS ARE ALSO STATED WE
CERTIFIED SO.
I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH A A
SWEDISH BUYER YESTERDAY THERE'S
A NEW TENDER.
FROM SWEDEN WHICH MEANS THAT'S
HOW THEY PURCHASE THERE ONE
THREE TENDERS.
AND THE WINERY NOT ONLY THE
GRAPES AND TO BE ASSISTING WITH
CERTIFIED THE WINERIES TO BE
SUSTAINABLE CERTIFIED SO THE
WINE INSTITUTE NOW HAS THE
CERTIFICATION.
ALMOST NO WINERIES HAVE IT YET
SO OURS HAS IT STARTING WITH THE
EIGHTEEN VANTAGE SO IT'S NOT
JUST THE CONSUMER I MEAN IT IS
ULTIMATELY BUT IF THE BUYER.
THE GATE KEEPER THAT'S LOOKING
FOR SUSTAINABILITY SO YOU ASKED
ABOUT STICKINESS OF OF CUSTOMERS
AND AUTHENTICITY.
A ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHANGES IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS AS DIGITAL
MARKETING.
THAT HELPS THE SUSTAINABILITY
I'M THE THE STICKINESS OF OF
YOUR CUSTOMERS -- I MEAN YOU
HAVE TO DO THAT NOW -- OR YOU
WANT ATTRACT CUSTOMERS YOU WON'T
YOU WON'T KEEP THEM IN A CUP AND
A QUANTITY IN THE I ALSO THINK
THE QUALITY OF YOUR PRODUCT.
ADS -- TO HOW LONG THEY STAY
WITH YOU YOU MIGHT GET A MENU
MUCH ALMOST YOUR CHOICE BUT IF
YOU MAKE A REAL HIGH QUALITY
PRODUCT AND YOU KEEP THAT UP.
AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO KEEP YOUR
YOUR CUSTOMERS.
IF I COULD JUST ORDER SOMETHING.
I THINK -- WHAT WHAT I'VE
NOTICED IN THE INDUSTRY IS THE
THERE'S A HUGE INTEREST IN
SUSTAINABILITY?
WHETHER TOM THE WINERY SIDE
PEOPLE COMING TO OUR WATER TO
SEE WHAT THEY CAN DO A THOROUGH
WATER YOU'RE THE VINEYARD -- I
PROBABLY SHOULD SEE THAT
INTEREST MORE OFTEN THAN I SEE
IT IN THE MARKETING.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THE REMEMBER THAT.
YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A FARMING
IT'S NEVER CULTURAL.
IN THOSE WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT I TALK TO ARE SO
INTERESTING SUSTAINABILITY --
THEY'RE INTERESTED BECAUSE THEY
WANT THE FORM TO BE THERE FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE KEY ISSUE
EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT USING IT FOR
MARKETING.
THANK YOU SENATOR IMMIGRATION.
YOU KNOW TOM YOU'VE GOT A GROUP
AUTOMATIC SO I JUST HAD A
COMMENT WILL BE OVER WORK ON THE
FUNNY BIT.
IT'S HARD FOR ME JUST TO BE
REALISTIC.
SEE THE THE GOVERNMENT'S GOING
TO GIVE ANY TYPE OF RESEARCH FOR
MARKETING OR THINGS THAT.
I MEAN.
MOVE YOUR MOVE IN THAT WAY BUT I
WOULD I WOULD SUGGEST THAT.
ON ALL THINGS CLIMATE.
AIR QUALITY WATER QUALITY LABOR
EAMER GYPSY PREPARED THIS.
THESE ARE THE AREAS THAT WE DO
HAVE POT SOMEBODY.
THAT PERHAPS GRANTS COULD BE
ISSUE WITH SUPPORT FROM MEMBERS.
SO WE LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU.
ALL THE ONE THAT.
IF YOU SAY THERE SEVEN HUNDRED
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS RESEARCH UC
DAVIS THERE'S A POT OF MONEY AND
HANNAH AREA NOT GONNA HAPPEN
[INAUDIBLE]
PERFECT.
WE WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR FIRST PANELIST
GIVE THE ROUND OF APPLIES AND
WONDERFUL WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR SHARING
THE PERSONAL STORIES AS WELL
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL.
THE GERMAN ON BEHALF OF CHAIR
DODD AND CHEER I WE ARE CURRY
WE'D LIKE TO BE A TRANSITION TO
OUR SECOND PANEL OUR SECOND
PANEL IS GONNA BE FOCUSING ON
EMERGING MARKETS IN APPELLATIONS
WE'RE GOING.
TO HAVE THEM BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
AT THIS TIME WE'RE THRILLED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE EXPERTS FROM
RIGHT HERE AT HOME REPRESENTING.
LAKE IN MANY IN CINEMA COUNTY
SOME EXPERTS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE FROM THE WINE INSTITUTE.
THEY'RE GOING TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND THE OPPORTUNITIES IN
ISSUES THE WINE INDUSTRY FACES
IN EMERGING MARKETS.
AND MARKETING YOU APPELLATION.
ANDY TALK ABOUT TRADE IN TERRACE
WE WANT TO APOLOGIZE AHEAD OF
TIME FOR ANY CUSSING DURING THE
TRADE IN TERROR OF CONVERSATION --
EACH PANELIST I. WILL HAVE FIVE
TO SEVEN MINUTES -- SO WE HAVE
PLENTY OF TIME FOR QUESTIONS IN
CONVERSATION.
AND WE ARE THRILLED TO KICK OFF
OUR PANEL WITH THE DEVER
SUMMERFIELD SHE IS THE HARD
WORKING PRESIDENT OF THE LAKE
COUNTY WINE GRAPE COMMISSION WE
WELCOME HER IN OUR PANEL. TO THE
HEARING THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE THIS SUMMER FIELD YOU
HAVE FIVE TO SEVEN MINUTES IN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS IN GOOD
AFTERNOON WE'RE GONNA GET THAT
CLICKER READY TO GO.
YEAH I WANNA MAKE SURE THE OUR
POWER POINT IS ON I BELIEVE AND
DOUBLE CHECK AT THE POWER POINT --
GIVE THIS ONE MOMENT.
WHICH I HIT THE BUTTON THERE
DIFFERENT.
AND WHERE WE GO [INAUDIBLE]
BILL [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE FIRED UP READY
TO GO SO. FIVE TO SEVEN BUSINESS
OUR FIELD THANK YOU AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE PAN OVER BEING.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND SOME REMEMBER WE ARE
CURRY -- TRIPLE THAT MIKE FOR
LOCAL CERTAINLY HIT THE BUTTON
RIGHT THERE RICHARD GREEN LIGHT
IS ON OKAY.
THANKS -- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND
SPEAK ABOUT -- BILLY COUNTY ONE
REGION.
WHAT MAKES A DISTINCT WHY GREAT
BUYERS AND ONE CONSUMERS ALIKE
ARE TAKING NOTICE?
PART OF THE NORTH COAST
APPELLATION ADJACENT TO CINEMA
MENDIS YOU KNOW AND NAPA.
COUNTIES KNOWN AS THE MOUNTAINS
OF THE NORTH COAST AS YOU CAN
SEE.
IT IS SITUATED ACROSS THE NEAR
TRIANGLE OF NORTH COAST MOUNTAIN
RANGES THE MAYACAMAS THE VIDAK
AS AND THE MENACING AMOUNT RANGE.
HERE SOME OF THE STATS ON OUR
REGION -- LEE COUNTY HAS NEARLY
TEN THOUSAND OF EIGHT ACRES OF
WINE GRAPES PLANTED GROUND BY
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
GROWERS.
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF THE CROP IS
PURCHASED BY WINERY BUYERS IN
NAPA AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
NORTH COAST.
SORRY YOUR BLOG AND CABERNET
SAUVIGNON TOGETHER MAKE UP ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF THE CROP AND
ANOTHER THIRD IS MADE UP BY
DOZENS OF OTHER RIVALS.
WAKE COUNTY IS PART OF THE NORTH
COAST AVA AND WITHIN LIKE COUNTY
THERE ARE SEVEN DESIGNATED ABA'S
INTO MORE CURRENTLY IN THE
PIPELINE WITH TTB.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT OUR REGION WE
TALK ABOUT THE DISTINCT
COMBINATION OF CLIMATE GEOLOGY
AND SOILS AND THE IMPACT ON THE
CHARACTER OF THE GRAPES AND ONCE?
THE MOST DISTINGUISHING FEATURE
IS THE ELEVATION THE MAJORITY OF
VINEYARDS ARE PLANTED ABOUT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED FEET.
HIGHER PUTS THREE DYNAMICS INTO
PLAY DRYER SHORTER AND COLDER.
LAKE COUNTY FRUIT RECEIVES
EXCELLENT UV EXPOSURE UP 210%
MORE UV THAN NEIGHBORING C.
LEVEL VALLEYS.
THAT INCREASED UV TRIGGERS
THICKER SKINS AND INTENSE WINDS
WITHIN ALL KLAY RIPE TANNINS.
WAKE COUNTY HAS POSITIONED
ITSELF AS A LEADER IN HIGH
ALTITUDE ONE GREAT PRODUCTION
THE REGION HAS HOSTED.
INTERNATIONAL SYMPOSIA THE
ELEVATION OF ONE PROGRAM.
AS A HIGH ELEVATION REGIONALLY
COUNTY HAS A DRIER CLIMATE AND
CONSISTENTLY MUCH LESS HUMIDITY
LITTLE TO NO FOG COMPARED TO ITS
NEIGHBORS IN FACT IT TYPICALLY
HAS ABOUT 50% LESS HUMID.
HUMIDITY THE NAPA DURING THE
GROWING SEASON.
DRY CONDITIONS HELP PREVENT ROT
AND THAT ALLOWS GROWERS TO USE
LESS SULFUR IN THE VINEYARD
WHICH FACILITATES FOR QUALITY
AND REDUCES OPERATIONAL COSTS.
LAKE COUNTY HAS A SHORTER
GROWING SEASON IN THIS LIMITS
VEGETATIVE GROWTH THAT CAN
INCREASE PEST PRESSURE.
COLDER WINTERS KILL OFF MANY
OVER WINTERING PASS AND BOTH OF
THESE FACTORS LEAD TO REDUCED
USE OF PESTICIDES AND HERBICIDES
IN THE VINEYARD.
THE REGION EXPERIENCES
SIGNIFICANT DIE ARE DIURNAL
SHIFT WITH WARM DAYS AND COOL
NIGHTS AND OFTEN A SWING OF MORE
THAN FIFTY DEGREES IN A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR PERIOD.
THIS FIXES DEEP COLOR WHILE
RETAINING NATURAL ACIDITY
CREATING COMPLEX WINES.
THE WIND FACTOR FROM THE LAKE
LENDS A MODERATING INFLUENCE AND
ALSO CONTRIBUTES TO THE CLEAR
SKIES ALL THESE FACTORS TOGETHER
CONTRIBUTE TO WINDS WITH PURITY
OF FRUIT.
HI NATURAL ACIDITY AND
RESTRAINED ALCOHOL WITH AND ALL
RIGHT MISS.
GEOLOGICALLY SPEAKING THIS
GRAPHIC SHOWS MANY OF THE
TECTONIC FORCES AT PLAY
INCLUDING THE NORTH COAST MAGMA
POCKET BENEATH NOT CANNOT DIE
THE PINK AREA THERE ON THE MAP.
WHICH WAS PREVIOUSLY UNDER
HOWELL MOUNTAIN AND OTHER PEAKS
MILLENNIA PRIOR.
AT THE CENTER OF THE COUNTY IS
MOUNT CANNOT DIE A DORMANT
VOLCANO NOT EXTINCT DORMANT --
THAT LAST REP AT APPROXIMATELY
ELEVEN THOUSAND YEARS AGO.
NO NO I KNOW RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
THAT'S ALRIGHT IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE COUNTY IS ROUND
MOUNTAIN A YOUNG CYNDER CONE AND
IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF THE
COUNTY AS YOU ALL KNOW IS THE
GEYSERS THE WORLD'S LARGEST
COMPLEX OF GEOTHERMAL ENERGY --
AND BECAUSE OF THE REGION'S
ERUPTIVE PAST -- YOU FIND A
DIVERSITY OF SOIL TYPES ACROSS
THE REGION DOMINATED BY ABOUT
YOUNG VOLCANIC SOILS THAT ARE
LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND YEARS OLD.
NOW AS AN ORGANIZATION MUCH OF
WHAT WE DO IS TO HELP EDUCATE
OUR GROWERS -- THROUGH
DEMONSTRATIONS SEMINARS AND
WORKSHOPS ALL FOCUSED ON
LEARNING MORE ABOUT HIGH
ELEVATION FARMING SUSTAINABLE
PRACTICES AND MARKET DEMANDS
TRENDS AND FORECASTS.
THE GEM OF OUR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM IS THE MASTER IN YOUR
OWN ACADEMY.
THIS IS ONE ORDERS ARE VERY
PROUD OF IT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY TWELVE AS THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM FOR SPANISH
SPEAKING VINEYARD SUPERVISORS --
TO DATE SEVENTY THREE GRADUATES
HAVE GONE THROUGH THE PROGRAM --
OR TWENTY NINETEEN CLASS THERE'S
NINE RIGHT NOW WHO ARE WRAPPING
UP IN AUGUST -- WE DO GRADUATION
NOVEMBER.
OVER THE COURSE OF EIGHT MONTHLY
SESSIONS THE CLASS VISITS
VINEYARDS AND WINERIES ACROSS
THE NORTH COAST AS WELL AS YOU
C. DAVIS.
FOUNDATION PLANT SERVICES AND
GREAT BY NURSERIES AND THE GROUP
TOWARDS THE TRADE SHOW FLOOR AT
THE UNIFIED ONE GREAT SYMPOSIUM
IN SACRAMENTO.
IN.
I JUST WANT TO SAY IN OUR FIRST
CLASS BACK IN.
TWENTY TWELVE THE CLASSES TORN A
LARGE WINERY IN SONOMA COUNTY.
AND ONE OF THE STUDENTS WAS A
VINEYARD SUPERVISOR WHO'D WORKED
IN VINEYARDS WERE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND HE LEANED OVER TO OUR
EDUCATION DIRECTOR.
AND HE SAID THAT IN IN ALL OF
HIS TIME HE HAD NEVER ACTUALLY
STEPPED FOOT INSIDE OF A WINERY.
SO THAT SAYS SOMETHING ABOUT THE
NEED OF THIS PROGRAM.
AS PART OF OUR MARKETING EFFORTS
WE PRESENT IN DEPTH TECHNICAL
SEMINARS FOR GREAT BUYERS TO
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCES OF WINE
GROWING IN OUR HIGH ELEVATION
REGION AS A WAY TO HELP INFORM
THEIR WINE MAKING.
WE INVITE SOMMELIERS IN WINDER
ACTORS TO COME TO OUR REGION FOR
A DEEP DIVE WITH TOURS ACROSS
THE ABA'S WITH OUR MOST
EXPERIENCED GROWERS.
AND TECHNICAL TASTINGS WITH OUR
MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE WINEMAKERS.
WE ALSO SIMILAR TRIPS TO WALKING
KEY MEMBERS OF THE WINE PRESS AS
WELL AS DISTRIBUTORS RETAILERS
AND OTHERS IN THE TRADE.
AND AS A SMALL ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING A SMALL REGION WE
TREASURE OUR PARTNERS WHO MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO DELIVER
TRULY HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMMING.
SEE A FEW OF THE LOVE IS THERE
THERE ARE MANY MORE THAT.
WOULDN'T FIT ON SLIDE.
AND WITH ALL THAT SAID WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN OVER TIME IS THAT THE
DISTINCT CHARACTER OF OUR
GROWING REGION COMBINED WITH A
GROWER COMMITMENT TO DELIVER
ONLY HIGH QUALITY GRAPES.
PRODUCED BY KNOWLEDGEABLE BEN
YOUR TEAMS HAS TRANSLATED INTO
BUYER DEMAND AND HIGHER GREAT
PRICES YEAR OVER YEAR.
OUR GROWERS ARE PROUD OF OUR
REGION AND WE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING US TO SHARE IT WITH YOU.
NICE JOB THANK YOU SO MUCH OF A
GREAT FOR THE HERE TODAY WE'RE
GONNA HOLD QUESTIONS IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH THE PANEL.
RIGHT TO THE END WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE OUR INTERVIEWS BURNED
IT.
SHE'S EXACTLY DRACULA MISSING A
WINE GROWERS INCORPORATED.
THAT WE SO APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE KNOW THAT YOU ARE WORKING
HARD EVERY DAY ON BEHALF OF
THESE YOU KNOW COUNTY WINE.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE AT FIVE
TO SEVEN MINUTES GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING US HERE HAPPY
TO REPRESENT NANCY NO COUNTY --
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE MENDOCINO WINEGROWERS INK WE
ARE A MARKETING ORGANIZATION OUR
JOB IS TO MARKET AND PROMOTE
MEDICINE A WINE AND GRAPE SO I'M
GONNA SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT.
IN OUR WORK -- HERE WITH YOU
TODAY.
SO FOR SOMEONE TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE UPDATE ABOUT THE MEDICINE --
COUNTY APPELLATION OUR
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES.
MADISON COUNTY IS A LARGE REGION
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION ACRES
WITH LESS THAN 1% OF THE TOTAL
ACREAGE PLANTED THE GRAPES.
THE AVERAGE SIZE OF OUR
INDIVIDUAL VINEYARDS ARE SMALL
FIFTEEN ACRES AND MOSTLY STILL
FAMILY OWNED.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN WINERIES IN
MEDICINE ACCOUNTING ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE THESE ARE BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITIES.
THESE WINERIES ARE MOSTLY IN
SMALL TO MID SIZE WINERIES WITH
JUST A FEW LARGE WINERY SUCH AS
FETZER PARDUCCI ROEDERER AND
SHARP FROM BURGER.
HAVING ONLY SMALL TO MID SIZE
WINERIES LIMITS THE MARKETING
CLOUT THAT THESE WINERIES HAVE
IN THE NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL MARKETER MARKING
PLACE.
THERE ARE NOT THE HUGE MARKETING
BUDGETS THAT LARGE WINERIES
WOULD HAVE TO MARKET THEIR
REGION -- AND THAT IS A
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY.
SO THE MENDOCINO GREAT MARKET
HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN A
COMMODITY MARKET.
MEDICINE A SELLS ABOUT 50% OF
OUR GRAPES OUTSIDE OF MENDOCINO
COUNTY MAINLY TO NAPA AND HERE
IN CINEMA COUNTY.
CHARDONNAY AND CABERNET ARE
DOMINANT VARIETALS REPRESENTING
CLOSE 250% OF THE TOTAL GREAT
PRODUCTION IN MENDOCINO COUNTY.
THESE POPULAR VARIETALS ARE
HIGHLY SOUGHT AFTER AS
ECONOMICAL BLENDERS -- IN CINEMA
AND NAPA WINES.
SO THE MENDOCINO GRAPE MARKET IS
CAUGHT IN A VICIOUS VOLATILITY
CYCLE.
PRICES SPIKED WITH DEMAND.
AND PRICES PLUNGE WHEN THE
MARKET IS SOFT.
LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN VINTAGE.
IT WAS A HUGE ADVANTAGE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THE TONNAGE
IN MENDOCINO COUNTY WAS UP 16%.
AND IN THE NORTH COAST THE
TONNAGE WAS UP 26%.
THIS HUGE CROP IN THE NORTH
COAST WILL DEFINITELY IMPACT THE
DEMAND FOR MENDOCINO COUNTY
FRUIT.
THE TOTAL VALUE OF THAT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN GRAPE CROP IN MENDOCINO
WAS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION THAT'S THE BIGGEST CROP
EVER FOR MENDOCINO COUNTY.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THE MARKET
IS.
RELATIVELY SOFT NOW DUE TO THE
HUGE CROP IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE THE WINE
MARKET IS RIYADH THEIR SLUGGISH.
BOOK MARKET ACTIVITY IS SLOW AND
BOLD INVENTORIES ARE INCREASING.
WINERIES ARE GRAPPLING WITH
INVENTORY FROM THE LARGE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HARVEST AND IN MANY
CASES.
CASES THE WINERIES ARE ALSO
SELLERS THEMSELVES OF GRAPES AND
WILK WINE.
HENCE THERE'S MORE GRAPES ON THE
SPARK SPOT MARKET IS WINERIES
HAVE GIVEN CONTRACT NOTICES TO
GROWERS.
AND ONE OF THE LARGE INDUSTRY
TRANSACTIONS THE CONSTELLATION
SALE TO GALLO.
ADDS TO OUR MARKET INSTABILITY
AND INSECURITY OF THOSE GREAT
CONTRACTS THAT WERE GOING TO
CONSTELLATION.
SO HOW DO WE CHANGE MEANT THE
SCENE -- AS A COMMODITY DRIVEN
MARKET.
MARKETING AND TOURISM.
WINE TOURISM SO IMPORTANT FOR
BRAND AWARENESS.
THE MENDOCINO ONE GROWERS HAS
PARTNERED WITH OUR COUNTIES DMO
OUR DESTINATION MARKETING
ORGANIZATION VISIT MENDOCINO
COUNTY.
WE'RE FOCUSING OUR MARKETING
EFFORTS ON OUR KEY MARKETS THAT
WOULD BE THE SAME SISCO BAY AREA
MARKET AND SACRAMENTO.
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER TO HOST
AND PROMOTE EVENTS THAT DROP IS
RESTORE REGION AND OUR TASTING
ROOMS.
BUT HOW CAN WE MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN THE LONG TERM SUCCESS AND
PROFITABILITY OF MENDOCINO
COUNTY WINE GRAPES.
WE BELIEVE IT IS CONJUNCTIVE
LABELING.
MEDICINE A ONE VERSUS BEEN
WORKING WITH CENTER MIKE MCGUIRE
FOR THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS. TO
DEVELOP AN ULTIMATELY PASS
CONJUNCTIVE LABELING FOR
MENDOCINO COUNTY.
CONJUNCTIVE LABELING.
LABELING OF A OF THE WIND TO
SHOW BOTH REGION AND THE SUB
REGIONS OF ORIGIN.
CONDUCTED LABELING IMPROVES
OVERALL COUNTY IN EVEN GREATER
SUB AVA RECOGNITION AND
AWARENESS.
THIS IS BEEN DONE SUCCESSFULLY
IN NAPA.
AND SONOMA COUNTY MODERATE PASO
ROBLES.
WHY CONJUNCTIVE LABELING?
THERE TO OVERREACHING REASONS
FOR PURSUING CONJUNCTIVE
LABELING.
FIRST TO CAPITALIZE ON THE RICH
HISTORY AND BRAND IDENTITY THAT
MENDOCINO COUNTY HAS WITH
CONSUMERS WORLDWIDE.
AND SECOND TO RAISE THE
AWARENESS OF THE ENTIRE WINE
GROWING REGION AS A COLLECTIVE
WHOLE.
CINEMA STATE UNIVERSITY'S WINE
BUSINESS INSTITUTE CONDUCTED A
STUDY TO EVALUATE THE IMPACT THE
CONJUNCTIVE LABELING HAD ON THE
CINEMA WINE REGION.
THE RESULTS SHOW THAT THERE WAS
A GREATER LEVEL OF AWARENESS AT
A REGIONAL LEVEL AND EVEN SO
EVEN MORE SO FOR THE SMALLER
APPELLATIONS OF THE COUNTY.
THIS FINDING INDICATES THAT
CONJUNCTIVE LABELING HAS HAD A
PAPPAS POSITIVE IMPACT ON
CONSUMER AWARENESS. FOR THE
CINEMA COUNTY AS A WINE REGION.
SO AGAIN WHY DOES MEDICINE A
COUNTY NEED CONDUCTED LABELING.
INCREASED RECOGNITION FOR EVERY
ABA WITHIN MENDOCINO COUNTY.
CONSISTENT MESSAGING EVERY
WINERIES TELLING THE SAME STORY
MENDOZA SCENE NOW.
MEDICINE NET MANY MEN THE SIERRA
COUNTY WINERIES ARE ALREADY
DOING CONJUNCTIVE LABELING.
IT IS BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED IN NAPA SONOMA
MONTEREY LODI IN PAST ROBLES.
THE BENEFIT FROM OUR PARTNER
WITH TOURISM VISIT MENDOCINO
COUNTIES CONSIDER RULING
CONSIDERABLE MARKETING EFFORTS
AND DOLLARS WILL HAVE A GREATER
IMPACT AND RESONANCE SAYING MEN
TO SEE YOU KNOW MENDOCINO COUNTY.
COME VISIT MENDOCINO COUNTY.
MILLENNIALS WANT TO ASSOCIATE
WITH THE PLACEMENT UNIQUE
HISTORY AND ITS UNIQUE STORY WE
NEED TO TELL THEM WHERE THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR WINES.
BILL PRESERVE AND STRENGTHEN OUR
POSITION IN THE WORLD WINE
MARKET AND INCREASE SALES AND
FROM WINES FROM MENDOCINO COUNTY
GRAPES.
SO HOW WE GONNA ABOUT DEVELOPING
A CONJUNCTIVE LABELING LAW FIRM
IN THIS IN A COUNTY.
WE REVIEWED HOW OTHER REGIONS
CRAFTED THEIR PROGRAMS.
WE POSTED SERIES OF REGIONAL
TOWN HALL MEETINGS ALL AROUND
BEN SEENA COUNTY WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS.
WE LISTEN TO THE CONCERNS AND
ADOPTED OUR PROPOSAL OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR FROM THOSE --
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS.
AND ULTIMATELY WITH CREST
CRAFTED A PROPOSAL THAT WILL BE
EFFECTIVE YEAH IT IS NOT
PROHIBITIVELY DIFF DIFFICULT.
IN THE SHORT MENDOZA CENA OR
MENDOCINO COUNTY MUST BE ON THE
FRONT OR BACK LABEL.
MEN THE CNO ALONE CAN BE USED IF
THE SUB ABA'S LOCATED WITHIN THE
MENDOCINO ABA.
AND WE'VE -- PROVIDED A GENEROUS
TIMELINE FOR COMPLIANCE DUE TO
THE COST FOR LABEL CHANGE EXCEPT
READ THAT LABELS MUST CONFORM TO
THIS LAW BY JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SO THIS PROPOSAL
WILL GO TO OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
EVERY GROWING VITNER IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY FOR A VOTE.
NEXT MONTH IN JULY.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL AND WE'RE CONFIDENT
YOU'LL MAKE A LASTING THIS
DIFFERENCE FROM ENCINO COUNTY
AND WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
THAT -- CENTER MCGUIRE HAS GIVEN
TO OUR EFFORTS -- AND WE'RE VERY
EXCITED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR AIDS NO
YOU HAVE BEEN WORKING --
DILIGENTLY I WILL SAY TO SAY THE
LEAST ON THIS ISSUE SO THIS WAS
HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE AND I KNOW --
EACH OF US LOVE SCENE D. OF
MINUTES YOU KNOW COUNTY.
WRAPPED LIGHT RAIL IN SACRAMENTO
I ONLY SEE YEAH LOOKS GREAT SO
NICE.
TO ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO MUCH
WONDERFUL JOB TODAY.
THIS IS GENERALLY NOW LIKE THEIR
TURN IT OVER TO MISTER MICHAEL
HE HE'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE EXACT ADDRESS FOR THE
CINEMA COUNTY VENDORS CHENEY'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU SIR
THANKS FOR YOUR WORK OF FIVE TO
SEVEN MINUTES IN YOUR FLOORS
YOURS WELCOME.
FANTASTIC THANK YOU ALL FOR
HAVING ME TODAY IT'S A REAL
HONOR TO BE HERE.
AND I WOULDN'T JUST TO START A
LITTLE BIT AND SAY A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT CINEMA COUNTY VENDORS --
WE ARE ACTUALLY -- THREE
COMPANIES IN ONE IF YOU LOOK AT
IT WE'RE OBVIOUSLY -- ONE OF US
AND WE WERE ONE OF SOME COUNTIES
LARGEST TRADE ASSOCIATIONS OUR
MISSION IS TO MARKET AND
REPRESENTS AND I'M CONNIE WINDS
IN WINERIES THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
WELL ACTUALLY I ALSO -- AND
EVENTS AND ACTIVITIES --
ACTIVATION COMPANY WE WE PRODUCE
SOME OF THE LARGEST TRADE AS
WELL AS CONSUMER WINE EVENTS
THROUGHOUT CINEMA COUNTY AND
ALSO SOME WE'RE VERY PROUD OF IS
OUR FOUNDATION AS WELL -- I CAN
TELL YOU I'M IN MY TWENTY NINTH
YEAR OF BEING IN THE WINE
INDUSTRY AND I CAN'T BE MORE
PROUD OF OUR WINE INDUSTRY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HERE FOR
THEIR GENEROSITY I CAN TELL YOU
IN JUST THIS YEAR ALONE SO FAR.
JUSTIN CINEMA COUNTY AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE WHAT CALIFORNIA IS DOING
AS A WHOLE BUT JUSTIN CINEMA
COUNTY.
OUR FOUNDATION HAS DONATED OVER
TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO OVER
SIXTY NONPROFITS THROUGHOUT
CINEMA COUNTY SO IT'S IT'S A
GREAT PRIDE TO BE HERE
REPRESENTING CINEMA COUNTY WINE
INDUSTRY TODAY.
I WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT -- THE MARKETS THAT -- WE
HAVE NOW AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
EMERGING MARKETS THAT WE SEE
COMING -- DOWN THE ROAD -- WE
THINK IT'S SOME KIND OF IT
THERE'S THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY
SOME GOOD NEWS AND WE ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THERE ARE.
WAYS TO GROW OUR MARKETS --
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD COMING UP
AND I WANT TO TOUCH ON NOT ONLY
THE THE INTERNATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE BUT A LITTLE BIT ON
THE DOMESTIC SIDE AS WELL.
ON THE INTERNATIONAL SIDE.
CURRENTLY OUR TOP INTERNATIONAL
MARKETS -- FOR CALIFORNIA ONCE
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD ARE THE
EUROPEAN UNION -- CANADA HONG
KONG.
JAPAN IN OF COURSE CHINA AS WELL.
MEANWHILE THOSE KIND OF EXISTING
MARKETS -- STILL HAVE MUCH ROOM
FOR GROWTH AND THAT'S EXCITING
IN ITSELF WE SEE SOME EMERGING
MARKETS ON THE INTERNATIONAL
FRONT AS WELL.
MEXICO SOUTH KOREA [INAUDIBLE]
INDIA.
VIETNAM IN GERMANY ALL OF THOSE
ARE SHOWING SIGNS OF INTERESTING
GROWTH FOR FOR CALIFORNIA WINES
AND THERE'S REASONS FOR THAT IF
YOU LOOK AT FOR EXAMPLE WINE
CONSUMPTION IN MEXICO IS ON THE
RISE.
JUST A GREAT THING CURIOSITY FOR
AMERICAN PRODUCTS IN GENERAL AS
WELL AS WINE IN VIETNAM IS ON
THE RISE.
OUR OUR REPUTATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA WINE REPUTATION IN
SOUTH KOREA'S OF A PREMIUM
NATURE.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE INCREASE
CONSUMER EDUCATION ABOUT
CALIFORNIA WINES IN GENERAL AND
ALL THESE COUNTRIES IS ON THE
INCREASE SO THOSE ARE SOME
EXCITING STATISTICS THERE TO
TALK ABOUT.
IN WITH THAT OUR WINERIES ARE
LOOKING TO ENGAGE IN THESE
MARKETS IN A VARIETY OF WAYS BUT
THERE ARE CHALLENGES AND SOME OF
THE PREVIOUS PANEL TALKED ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE BIT ONE OF THEM IS
THE THE WELL FUNDED PROMOTION OF
WINES BY INTERNATIONAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WE TALKED ABOUT.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT YOU'RE.
THE E. U. ALONE SPENDS OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN MARKETING
PROMOTION AND GRAPES AS THE
SUBSIDIES EACH YEAR -- SO THAT
THAT'S A GREAT ASSISTANCE TO
THAT MARKET OBVIOUSLY THE THE
TERROR FROM TRADE FRICTIONS THAT
WE C..
OUR CHALLENGE TO OUR INDUSTRY --
BREXIT UNCERTAINTY IS A
CHALLENGE AND OF COURSE OUR OUR
COMPETITIVE PRICE DISADVANTAGE
EXPRESSLY IN ASIA MARKET NOW IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO
GRAPPLE WITH -- ALL THE TIME AS
WELL.
HOWEVER I CAN TELL YOU -- THAT
WE WHEN WE HAVE SUCH GREAT
RESOURCES AS OF IS THESE
WONDERFUL ONE ASSOCIATIONS IN
THE WINE INSTITUTE I THINK BY
WORKING TOGETHER WITH.
WITH THESE TYPE OF ORGANIZATIONS
AS WELL AS OUR WINERIES ACROSS --
CALIFORNIA I THINK YOU'LL SEE
SOME FANTASTIC GROWTH IN SOME OF
THESE INTERNATIONAL MARKETS IN
THE NEXT DECADE BECOMES WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
AND ALSO ON THE DOMESTIC SIDE WE
ALL KNOW ABOUT MILLENNIALS AND
SO FORTH WHILE I THINK
PERSONALLY THAT THE THE POSITIVE
IMPACT ON WINE SALES -- IN THE
PAST YEAR OR SO WAS MAYBE A
LITTLE OVER ESTIMATED FROM
MILLENNIALS WE SEE THE WINE
INDUSTRY NOW REALLY ENGAGING IN
FORMATS TO PROMOTE.
OUR WINDS TO MILLENNIALS IN WAYS
THAT ARE ATTRACTIVE TO THEM -- I
THINK FOR EXAMPLE YOU SEE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT MILLENNIALS ARE
MORE DIGITALLY FOCUSED SO NOW
YOU C. WINERIES GETTING INVOLVED
IN MORE DIGITAL PLATFORMS TO
COMMUNICATING WITH MILLENNIALS
ALSO -- MILLENNIALS LIKE MORE
CHOICES I MEAN I LIKE MORE
CHOICES AND M. FAR FROM
MILLENNIAL BUT SO YOU SEE THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY LOOKING TO
PROVIDE MORE WINES BY THE GLASS
ACROSS THE BOARD WHICH IS A GOOD
THING AS WELL.
ALSO WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL THE THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUSTAINABILITY.
ORGANIC TO MILLENNIALS AND
OTHERS AS WELL -- THAT'S A GREAT
IMPORTANCE I CAN TELL YOU AND I
CAN TELL YOU WERE VERY PROUD IN
CINEMA COUNTY IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT MY COUNTERPARTS OF DONE.
IN -- WITH CINEMA COUNTY GRAPE
GROWERS AND CHRIS A CRUISE IN
HER FANTASTIC TEAM WE ARE NOW
OVER 95% VINEYARD SUSTAINABLE
CERTIFIED IN CINEMA COUNTY.
AND THAT WAS A FIVE YEAR GOAL
THAT THEY MET IT'S IT'S JUST A
FANTASTIC -- STATEMENT TO BE
ABLE TO MARKET.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE TALKED
ABOUT WINERIES CREATING VARIOUS
EXPERIENCES WELL ENGAGING THOSE
MILLENNIALS IN CREATING THOSE
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE ATTRACTIVE
TO THEM ARE VERY IMPORTANT AND
THEN OF COURSE JUST THE THE
INCREASING CONVENIENCE --
MILLENNIALS ARE LACKING WINDS
NOW WHETHER THEY BE IN CANS OR
OTHER DELIVERY METHODS -- TO
MAKE IT MORE CAN IT'S TO THEM
WHETHER IT'S BY THE POOL ON THE
LAKE OR WHOEVER MAYBE SO THE
WIND INJURE INDUSTRY NOW IS
ENGAGING I THINK IN A MUCH MORE --
POSITIVE IN IN PROMOTIONAL WAY
TO ENGAGE THAT TYPE OF OF OF
MARKET HERE.
ALSO WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT I
DIDN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
COUPLE OF CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE
SEEING.
IN OUR MARKETS IN RIGHT JOHNSON
TOUCHED ON SOME OF THOSE -- NOT
ONLY ARE WE COMPETING ON A
GLOBAL SCALE WITH OUR WINDS AND
WE WE COMPETE WITH LABOR ISSUES
AS WELL ANOTHER CONCERNS AS RAY
TALKED ABOUT.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
SEE YOU HERE IN CINEMA COUNTY I
KNOW OTHER ASSOCIATIONS ARE
DEALING WITH IT IS THE PROBLEM
PROBLEMATIC PERMIT PROCESS WE
ALL KNOW THERE NEEDS TO BE
REGULATIONS AND SO FORTH BUT THE
PROCESS ITSELF HAS BECOME A REAL
CHALLENGE THAT OUR ORGANIZATION
SPENDS.
QUITE A BIT OF TIME ADDRESSING --
EVERY WEEK -- I CAN TELL YOU OF
ONE EXIT RECENT EXAMPLE WE HAD A
WINERY -- IT WAS AN EXISTING
WINERY THAT WENT TO BUILD A NEW
FACILITY -- AND THAT -- PROCESS
TWO SIX YEARS.
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS JUST TO GET THE YES.
INTO THE POINT NOW FOR THAT
PROJECT WHILE IT IS APPROVED --
IS DELAYED A YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
MONEY SPENT ON JUST GETTING THAT
YES SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
CINEMACON INVENTORS OF WAYS AND
WE'RE INTO CS TO COAL TO WORK
WITH OUR COUNTY OFFICIALS AND
AND OTHERS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN REFINE AND
REVIEW THAT PROCESS.
IN TO BRING FOR A PROGRAM THAT
THAT THAT LIMITS THAT TIME LINE
AS WELL AS EDUCATE -- POTENTIAL
APPLICANT ON WHAT THAT MAXIMUM
COSTS COULD POSSIBLY BE SO THEY
CAN BUDGET AND AND PLAN ON THAT
AS WELL.
AND THEN RAY ALSO TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER THE IMPORTANCE OF DIRECT
TO CONSUMER.
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THE
DIRECT CONSUMER IS ALL ABOUT
SURVIVAL FOR THIS WINE INDUSTRY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THROWING PARTIES
IT'S NOT ABOUT NECESSARILY PAN
YOUR BANK ACCOUNT IS TRULY ABOUT
SURVIVAL IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AVERAGE FAMILY OWNED WINERY --
SICK IT'S 61%.
OF THE REVENUES IS DIRECT TO
CONSUMER -- SO.
SOME OF THE PERMIT PROCESS IS IT
REGARDING DIRECT CONSUMER FOR
EXAMPLE IS ALSO -- PROBLEM THAT
WE NEED TO ENGAGE IN AND REVIEW
FOR EXAMPLE ON THE WINERY EVENTS
AND ACTIVITIES SIDE -- I THINK
IF YOU LOOK AT HOW THE MARKETS
CHANGE ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
THE NUMBER OF WHOLESALERS ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES HAS
DRAMATICALLY BEEN REDUCED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
WHILE THE NUMBER OF WINERIES HAS
INCREASED SO EVEN IF I WANT --
WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTION DOESN'T
MEAN I'M GOING TO GET IT SO THAT
DIRECTORS CONSUMER -- CHALLENGE
OR CHANNEL IS MY LIFE'S BLOOD TO
SURVIVE ABILITY WITH ABOUT ONE
MINUTE.
YES ABSOLUTELY.
NO IN ONE MINUTE ONE MINUTE ONE
MINUTE YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ATKINS I COULD KEEP GOING ON
DOING GREAT.
WELL THANK YOU WELL BUT IN THE
IN IN IN SUMMARY I I CAN TELL
YOU ON THESE PROBLEMS AND OTHERS
WE ARE EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO
WORK COLLECTIVELY WITH OUR WITH
OUR NEIGHBORS WITH OTHER
ASSOCIATIONS IN WITH OUR
POLITICAL -- REPRESENTATIVES TO
BE ABLE TO COORDINATE ANSWERS TO
THESE PROBLEMS AND OTHERS BUT
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME NO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR VERY
GRATEFUL THINKING TRAINING FOR
BEING HERE FOR ALL YOUR WORK.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
MISTER SCHMELZER ASSISTANCE
RATHER HE IS THE VICE PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA STATE RELATIONS FOR
THE WINE INSTITUTE.
WE'VE HEARD -- CHALLENGES IN
EMERGING MARKETS AS WELL THE
APPELLATIONS FROM CINNAMON IN
THE SCENE OR LAKE NOW WE'RE
GONNA TAKE -- MORE GLOBAL VIEW
ON THE STATEWIDE LEVEL
DISCLOSURE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU HAVE AT FIVE TO SEVEN
MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND GERMAN INTER WOMAN --
PLEASURE TO BE HERE -- SO I'M
GONNA BE DOING MY BEST FAKE IT
TILL I MAKE IT TO TALK ABOUT
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS.
AND I'M -- SO BE PATIENT WITH ME --
ANYWAY I FIRST WANT -- TO JUST --
GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF PERSPECTIVE
OF WORK CALIFORNIA STANDS AND SO
THE INTERNATIONAL MARKETS AND
AND A LITTLE BIT ONE INSTITUTES
ROLE IN -- PROMOTING THAT ALL --
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AND WILL PROBABLY
HAVE TO BEAT THAT FOR THE
TELEVISION AUDIENCE AND WE'RE
ALL AWARE ABOUT -- ANYWAY -- I
THINK YOU'RE ALL AWARE
CALIFORNIA IS THE FOURTH LARGEST
PRODUCER OF WINE IN THE WORLD --
IN 85% -- THE WINE -- PRETTY C.
UNITED STATES COMES FROM
CALIFORNIA AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
FOR THIS CONVERSATION 95% OF THE
WINE -- EXPORTED FROM THE UNITED
STATES IT COMES FROM CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S DUE TO THIS -- OUTSIZED
ROLE THE CALIFORNIA PLAYS IN
WINE EXPORTS -- THAT IT'S COME
TO PASS THE WINE INSTITUTE --
PLACE SUCH A LARGE ROLE AND
HELPING WITH OUR EXPORT
MARKETING -- MY COLLEAGUE HONOR
COMFORT WHO UNFORTUNATELY WASN'T --
ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY -- WE SET
UP -- FOR ON BEHALF OF ONE
INSTITUTE -- THEY WANT TO
MENTION JUST SOME OF THE HUGE
NUMBER OF EVENTS THAT -- WE BOTH --
HOST TO PARTICIPATE IN -- TO
SUPPORT -- CALIFORNIA'S EXPORT
POTENTIAL I HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
JUST THIS YEAR -- WE POSTED THE
SOMMELIERS FROM MEXICO -- WE
POSTED FOLKS FROM THE U. K. FROM
THE NORDIC REGION'S -- FROM
JAPAN UK AND IRELAND.
AND COMING IN EARLY -- TWENTY
TWENTY WE HAVE FOLKS COMING FROM
ASIA AND A EUROPEAN MEDIA GROUP --
TOURING ACROSS THE WORLD -- WE
PARTICIPATE -- AND HOST EVENTS
IN ASIA CANADA EUROPE JAPAN
MEXICO U. K. AND IRELAND SO
COVER HUGE SWAP -- OF THE WORLD --
PUSHING THE MESSAGE THAT BOTH
CALIFORNIA AND AND OFTEN IN OUR
OLD -- PROMOTE -- AMERICAN --
ONE ABROAD.
OF COURSE -- THERE ARE
CHALLENGES OUT THERE THAT ARE
VERY SIGNIFICANT FOR US AND
WHILE WE ARE VERY PROUD TO SAY
THAT -- OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
OUR EXPORTS HAVE GONE UP OVER
60% WHICH I THINK IS AN AMAZING
ACHIEVEMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY IT THE TREND HAS
BEEN DOWNWARD THESE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS I'LL LET YOU SPEAK TO
WHY.
OF THIS -- LAST YEAR IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR EXAMPLE --
THE VALUE -- WINE EXPORTS --
WITH DOWN FOUR POINT 6%.
AND YEAH THAT'S A LOT OF THAT
HAS TO DO WITH THE TRADE WAR
STUFF THAT -- WE'RE GONNA ENGAGE
TO TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT HERE --
SO YOU KNOW WHERE OUR PRIMARY
MARKETS ARE -- THE E. U. --
HOW'S THE CROWN -- FOR THE
SINGLE LARGEST REGION -- BUYER
OF CALIFORNIA WINE -- IN WE
MICHAEL MENTIONED THIS IS WELL
CANADA'S SECOND -- BECAUSE HONG
KONG JAPAN CHINA MEXICO GOT
NUMBERS FOR THOSE -- SHOULD YOU
BE INTERESTED -- MANY OF OUR
CHALLENGES STEM FROM THE FACT
THAT -- THERE'S TERRORISTS AND
OTHER PROTECTIVE MEASURES --
THAT WE ARE FACED WITH WHEN WE
PUSH OUR PRODUCTS ABROAD.
AND PRODUCTS COMING IN THE
UNITED STATES OFTEN DON'T FACE
ANYTHING SIMILAR -- FOR EXAMPLE --
THE TERROR FOR A BOTTLE STILL
WIND COMING INTO CALIFORNIA IS
FIVE CENTS -- IT'S OVER DOUBLE
THAT -- FOR US TO SEND WINE INTO
EUROPE -- JUST AS ONE EXAMPLE --
THAT NUMBER.
CLIENTS EXPONENTIALLY DEPENDING
ON WHAT COUNTRIES ARE TALKING
ABOUT -- IN JAPAN THAT TERROR
PHRASES -- 15% NOW -- THERE WERE
HAPPY THAT THERE'S ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS WITH JAPAN THAT
PERHAPS THE DRESS THAT -- IN
INDIA -- NUMBERS A HUNDRED AND
50% AND NOTABLY HAVING RECENTLY
VISITED THERE I DIDN'T SEE A LOT
OF CALIFORNIA WHAT [INAUDIBLE]
YES.
YOUR THERE'S WELL THAT'S RIGHT --
ANYWAY -- I'LL ENDEAVOR TO TALK --
REGION BY REGION -- WHERE WHERE
WE FACE CHALLENGES AND -- AND
HAPPY TAKE SOME QUESTIONS A
DEEPER DIVE IN SOME OF THIS --
THE EUROPEAN UNION -- POSES
CHALLENGES -- NOT SOUND ON THE
TERROR OF ISSUE THAT I THAT I
MENTIONED -- BUT ALSO AND AND
MICHAEL AGAIN YOU TOUCHED ON
THIS -- THEY THEY MAINTAIN A
HUGE ADVANTAGE AND US AND THE
SUPPORT THEY GET FOR MARKETING
OF THE PRODUCT -- YOU KNOW WE DO
SOMERSAULTS WHEN WE GET A SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT -- BUT
COMPARED TO WHAT WAS THE NUMBER
YOU'RE USING LIKE A TOTAL YEAH.
YEAH.
AND IT'S IT'S YOU KNOW THE
NUMBERS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES SO --
YOU KNOW THAT'S A CHALLENGE FOR
US OBVIOUSLY -- THERE'S A
THERE'S OTHER LITTLE THINGS IN
THE IN THE EUROPEAN UNION -- YOU
KNOW GOD BLESS MY LIVE VISITING
EUROPE AND AND YOU KNOW -- THEY
ENDEAVOR TO GET AT THIS BUT IT'S
LIKE A DEATH FROM A THOUSAND
CUTS KIND OF APPROACH HERE --
THEY MAINTAIN AN ABSOLUTE
MONOPOLY.
ON THE USE OF GEOGRAPHICAL
INDICATIONS -- FOR EXAMPLE THAT
YOU CAN USE ON A BOTTLE OF WINE --
CALIFORNIA -- ONE CAN'T SAY FOR
EXAMPLE THE WORD CHATEAU ON IT
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SELL IT IN
EUROPE AND THERE ARE OVER A
THOUSAND OF THESE TYPE OF OF
LABELS THAT -- ARE ALL PART OF
THE RULES.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE.
TO WAIT WE RESEARCH THE THEY
CAN'T SAY CLASSIC OR CREAM WHICH
I CAN'T EVEN RECALL SEEING ON A
BOTTLE OF WINE BUT ANYWAY BUT
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST LIKE LITTLE
THINGS LIKE THAT BECAUSE THEY
POSE CHALLENGES -- INTERESTINGLY
ALSO IN EUROPE -- THEY HAVE A
LOT OF FOCUS ON THE USE OF CROP
PROTECTION MATERIALS -- THAT
THAT -- WE USED TO PROTECT THE
GRAPES AND HAVE ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS -- ASKED WINERIES TO
TEST THEIR WINES FOR CERTAIN
CHEMICALS THAT MAY EXIST IN A
WINE AND TO MY KNOWLEDGE IS
ALMOST ALWAYS COME BACK MAYBE
NEGATIVE.
BUT IT'S A GREAT EXPENSE TO
ANYONE -- TO HAVE TO DO THIS
JUST -- TO BILL TO PUT YOURSELF
IN THE EXPORT MARKET.
AND JUST HOPE THAT THREAT
HOVERING OVER THAT THAT WE MAY I
ASK SOMEBODY TO DO THAT HAS AN
EFFECTIVE DEPRESSING -- SO -- I
WENT INTO JUST ONE MORE THING --
YOU -- LIKELY RIGHT IN THE NEWS
THIS WHOLE BUSINESS -- ABOUT
AIRBUS AND THE TRADE ISSUES THAT
THAT'S CREATING -- BELIEVE OR
NOT -- CAL CALIFORNIA WINE --
MAY GET CAUGHT UP IN THAT IS AS
WELL AND WE COULD -- SEE
ACTUALLY I EVEN A HIGHER TERROR
ON OUR PRODUCTS GOING INTO
EUROPEAN UNION.
AS YOU KNOW KIND OF THE FRIENDLY
FIRE FROM -- THAT EXCHANGE --
YEAH IT'S ONE CAUGHT UP IN IT
WHICH IS A REAL SHAME -- IN
CHINA OF YOU KNOW WHAT SPOKE TO
THE COMMITTEE -- LAST YEAR ABOUT
THIS ISSUE -- THAT'S GOING FROM
BAD TO WORSE -- YOU KNOW IT I
THINK A YEAR AND A HALF AGO --
THE TERROR OF ON CALIFORNIA ONE
IN A CHINA WAS LIKE 15% --
BEGINNING IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR
WERE AT NINETY THREE SO.
BUT THE UGLY AND IS THE REAL
SHAME THERE -- CHINA'S SOMETHING
LIKE THE IT'S DOWN THE LIST A
LITTLE BIT AS FAR AS WINE
EXPORTS FOR CALIFORNIA. FOR
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS COMPARED TO LIKE
EUROPEAN UNION WHICH IS LIKE
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
BUT THERE'S SO MUCH POTENTIAL
THERE AND WE'VE PLAYED SO MUCH
GROUND WORK.
AND TO HAVE YOU KNOW KIND OF OUR
GROUND TAKEN OUT FROM UNDER US --
IN THOSE UPPER WITH THIS TRADE
WAR.
IS A TERRIBLE SHAME AND REALLY
HURTS OF THE FUTURE POTENTIAL --
FOR CALIFORNIA WINE EXPORTS SO --
THAT'S A TOUGH ONE AND AND
HONESTLY I DON'T SEE THE END OF
THAT ONE RIGHT NOW SO -- TAKING
CUTS ON ALLEN IF YOU PLAY -- ON
THE MORE POSITIVE -- THINGS I
CAN TALK ABOUT -- WITH BEN AND
OKAY.
THERE'S LOTS TO TALK ABOUT WITH
POSITIVE RIGHT NOW SO THAT -- AT
FIRST SOMEWHAT IRONICALLY.
THIS -- BRIGGS IT BUSINESS IN
THE U. K. -- ACTUALLY CREATE
SOME OPPORTUNITY FOR US -- YOU
HEARD ME -- GIVE YOU CHAPTER AND
VERSE ABOUT OUR CHALLENGES WITH
THE E. U. -- SHOULD BRAGS THAT
FINALLY GET FINALIZED -- THIS
ACTUALLY CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO NEGOTIATE DIRECTLY --
WITH THE U. K. AND WE HOPE --
CREATE BETTER -- TRADE
AGREEMENTS -- WITH THEM AND AND
WE THINK THAT WE ACTUALLY WELL --
AND THEN I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION REAL -- QUICKLY AND
ACTUALLY IT.
WE HAVE CHALLENGES IN IRELAND
THEY'RE THEY'RE TOUGH BUT I WANT
TO MENTION ONE MORE POSITIVE
THING -- IN CANADA -- WHICH
WE'VE THE LATEST AGREEMENT WITH
THE I FORGET WHAT IT'S CALLED
THE IT'S A GOOD NAFTA
REPLACEMENT THAT'S BEEN THAT'S
BEEN A GOOD THING -- BOTH FOR
MEXICAN AND CANADIAN TRADE AND
WE ARE HAPPY JUST TO SEE THAT --
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME REGIONAL
STRUGGLES -- WITHOUT IN ONTARIO
AND QUEBEC -- ANY RATE -- I KNOW
SEVERAL OF YOU ARE PROBABLY
WARRIOR SOUNDS WHICH YOU KNOW.
SORRY YOU LOST BUT THERE IS A
GOOD THING THAT HAPPENED HERE.
AND THAT THERE WAS A BACK
BETWEEN -- SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
AND THE PRIME MINISTER I DO NOT
WRITE JUSTIN TRUDEAU.
AND THE BETH FROM CALIFORNIA WAS
IF THE WARRIORS LOST YOU KNOW
WHICH IS TOO BAD SORRY M. KINGS
FOUND BUT WHATEVER -- WE'RE ON A
UPWARD TREND.
THANK YOU SHE KNOWS.
ANY RATE -- IS A SOMEWHAT JERKY
NOTE THOUGH BUT THE BUT SPEAKING
HELLO C. -- AS A RESULT OF THE
WARRIORS LOSING THE THE SILVER
LINING IS THAT AND THAT IS THAT --
FROM MISTER TRUDEAU RECEIVED --
SEVERAL CASES OF CALIFORNIA WINE
WHICH WILL UNDOUBTEDLY TURNED
INTO YOU CHOOSE WE HAVE IN
CANADA AROUND.
IT ALL IN MY PRESENTATION THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SMELLS ARE
WHAT WE LIKE TO GO TO DO NOW IS
OPEN UP TO THE COMMITTEE --
WE'RE GONNA START WITH GERMAN
GUY WITH ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR.
THINK OF THIS IS KIND OF MORE
FOR THE NEWER APPELLATIONS -- IS
THEIR UNIQUE CHALLENGES NEW
NEWER APPELLATIONS THAT -- DON'T
SEEM AS PREVALENT IN.
YEAH WITH THE WITH THE OLDER
ONES.
SO -- WHAT I WOULD SAY IS TRYING
TO CREATE THE BRAND AWARENESS
FOR A BRAND NEW APPELLATION --
BOTH HAS ITS -- YOU KNOW
CHALLENGES BUT ALSO
OPPORTUNITIES I THINK A PETALUMA
GAP.
IN CINEMA COUNTY WHICH IS DONE
AN EXCELLENT JOB OF MARKETING --
I THINK IT MAYBE THEY ALSO ARE
THEY ARE TIED TO AN ACTUAL PLACE
THE PEOPLE MAY HAVE HEARD OF BUT
THEY HAVE A VERY UNIQUE STORY TO
TELL -- AND SAID THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY DO A GREAT
JOB OF CREATING YOUR BRAND WHEN
YOU'RE A BRAND NEW APPELLATION
AND YOU'RE VERY FOCUSED ON WHAT
IT IS.
AND WHO YOU ARE AND WHAT YOU'RE
PRODUCING -- SO I SEE THAT AS A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
COLDER REGIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
AROUND SUCH IS MAN'S YOU KNOW
LAKE CINEMA -- YOU KNOW WE'RE
KIND OF LIKE YEAH YEAH YEAH YOU
KNOW SO HOW DO WE GET THROUGH
THE NOISE.
AND CREATE THE AWARENESS OF WHAT
WE'RE ALL ABOUT -- AND BECAUSE A
LARGER REGIONS HAVE.
THE SMALLER ABA'S THAT HAVE THE
UNIQUENESS IT'S IT'S KIND OF A
CHALLENGE TO BRING THAT ALL
UNDER ONE UMBRELLA [INAUDIBLE]
WHAT IS?
I AM SURE -- COUPLE QUICK --
COMMENTS FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
THANK DEBORAH FOR WHAT SHE'S
DONE FOR LAKE COUNTY -- WE
REPRESENT ALL OF US OF REPRESENT
LAKE COUNTY AND THERE'S BEEN SO
MANY THINGS AND UP THERE AND
TRYING TO GET ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT GOING UP THERE SO.
BUT I WANT TO SAY IS THAT --
IT'S AMAZING THE WANTING TO
STRIP THERE.
AND I WHEN I FIRST STARTED
WORKING UP THERE I HAD NO CLUE
AND THEN I HAD THE BEST WINE
WHITE WINE THERE WAS A THE BEST
WHITE ONES IN CALIFORNIA.
REALLY COUNTY AND I THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD KNOW THAT OR MORE SO I
APPLAUD YOU AND I WOULD LIKE TO
BE INVITED TO WILK AGREE TO
DISAGREE BUT AND YOU KNOW I CAN
SAY THAT IS THAT I DON'T
REPRESENT.
A MID TO SENIOR COUNTY A LITTLE
TINY FEET WELL ACTUALLY I CAN
WITH THAT BUT WE CAN.
BUT I I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
FACT THAT WHAT YOU'VE DONE UP
THERE TO BRING -- SOME BIT OF
TOURISM AND BUT IT'S ALSO
DIFFICULT TRYING TO REALLY GET
IT GOING AND GETTING THE
MARKETING GOING UP THERE -- I
WAS A I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
FARM WORKERS.
AND I THOUGHT THOSE WERE THE
FIRST TIMES I HAD SEEN THE
LEADERSHIP ROLES OF THE FARM
WORKERS ARE TAKING ON AN
GRADUATING FROM A CLASS AND THAT
MADE MY HEART FULL AND I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING UP THERE I'D LIKE
TO BE INVITED TO WHENEVER YOU'RE
EVENTS AND I'D LIKE TO SIT IN
THE AUDIENCE IN HERE WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH LOVE TO HAVE YOU
AND EXTEND THE INVITATION TO ALL
THREE OF YOU OF COURSE THAT AT
ANY.
TIME.
BUT ONE THING THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON THE WOOD WILL INCLUDE
ALL OF YOU -- IS A SCENIC
HIGHWAY.
FOR ONE TWENTY EIGHT AND THE
REASON THAT CAME UP IS BECAUSE
OF ALL THE FIRES AND SO MANY OF
OUR FARMERS A WINERY SAID WE
NEED TO GET SOMETHING GOING FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
SO WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF OF
GETTING -- SCENIC HIGHWAY
APPROVED FOR THE MENDOCINO COAST
ALL THE WAY TO MY HOMETOWN
WINTERS CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE
PRETTY EXCITED ABOUT THAT WE'RE
JUST GOT TO GET SOME THINGS NAIL
DOWN THAT BUT IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
GONE THROUGH ALL THIS THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE SO ANYTHING
WE CAN DO TO HELP.
WITH MARKETING OF OUR WINES IN
CALIFORNIA IS IMPORTANT SO -- I
THINK THAT'S ALL I HAVE RIGHT
NOW I'M SURE YOU TALK AFTERWARDS
BUT THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT WITH
ALL OF YOU DO.
INTENSE JUST THE BEST TO COME TO
SEE THIS ON A REGULAR BASIS
PICTURES ACCOUNTS ON THE HEAD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH VENTURE I IF
YOU ALL CAN TALK ABOUT.
AS THE ENHANCED FOCUS AND DIRECT
SALES -- AND WHAT THAT MEANS AND
THEN AT THE MARKETING CAMPAIGN
THAT GOES WITH THAT DENTURE THAT
WE ARE GETTING.
TALES IN THE TASTING ROOMS RIGHT
TO BE A PURCHASE THAT WIND SO
CAN YOU GIVE US SOME --
DIRECTIONAL WHERE EACH OF THE
COUNTIES ARE GOING.
PUSHING THAT MARKETING BRINGING
FOLKS IN THE COUNTY AND WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR ME THE WINERIES
REGARDS DISTRICT SALES.
I DO WE'LL START WITH EVER MORE
CAR WAY DOWN MIKE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DO THE LIGHTNING ROUND.
AND SO THE WHOLE WAY SO IT'S
GREAT PLEASE.
YEAH I THINK -- FOR REGION LIKE
OURS DIRECT TO CONSUMERS IS HUGE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT IN THIS DAY
AND AGE AND ALL OF OUR WINERIES
UNDERSTAND THAT -- THEY FROM A
TOURISM PERSPECTIVE YOU CAN GET
A VISITOR TO THE COUNTY -- THEY
WILL DIRECT THEM TO OTHER
NEIGHBORING WINERIES AND THERE'S
A VERY COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT
THERE BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND HOW
HARD IT IS TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
FROM THE BAY AREA TO COME UP
THROUGH EITHER SO NORMAL OR NOT
BUT TO COME TO LAKE -- FOR VERY
SMALL WINERIES IT'S CRITICAL
IT'S THEIR LIFE BLOOD -- WE ARE
SEEN TURNOVER AND THINK THIS IS
A TREND IN THE INDUSTRY -- WHERE?
OUR OLDER GENERATIONS MAY STICK
WITH HELLO A ONE CLUB MEMBERSHIP
OVER YEARS WERE SEEN MORE
TURNOVER NOW I THINK.
AND AND I'M SURE OTHERS ON THE
PANEL CAN TALK A LITTLE BIT TO
THAT SO THAT IS A CONCERN WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT DIRECTING
SUMMER ONE CLUB IS A BIG PART OF
THAT.
SO -- AGAIN BEING --
DEMOGRAPHICALLY REALLY.
CHALLENGED -- REGIONS GETTING
SOMEONE IN THE TASTING ROOM IS
HE KEEPING -- IS YOU KNOW SUPER
IMPORTANT I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES -- FOR SMALL TO MID
SIZE WINERIES IS THE TECHNOLOGY
IN THE FOLLOWING UP WITH THAT
CONSUMER THEY'VE HAD A WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCE THEY LOVE THE WINE.
MAYBE YOU MAIL -- TWO TO THREE
ONE CUP SHIPMENTS HERE BUT WHAT
DO YOU DO IN.
THE TWELVE MONTHS A YEAR TO
ENGAGE THEM TO KEEP THEM LOYAL
TO TELL YOUR STORY.
AND MOST OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES --
THE WINE MAKERS WORKING THE
TASTING ROOM AND THE WIFE IS
DOING THIS AND THAT AND YOU KNOW
TO TO BE.
AS SOPHISTICATED AS YOU NEED TO
BE THESE DAYS TO COMPETE IN THE
MARKETPLACE I THINK IS IS REALLY
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AS I SAID EARLIER DIRECT
CONSUMER IS ALL ABOUT SURVIVAL
FOR WINERIES I THINK AND I CAN
TELL YOU IS BERNADETTE SAID
WINERIES ARE ARE ENGAGING NOW
MORE AND MORE ON THOSE YEAR LONG
TOUCH POINTS WITH CONSUMERS
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT ALSO ONE OF THE INITIATIVES
THAT WE'RE UNDERTAKING IN CINEMA
COUNTY OF ADVENTURES.
IS IS CREATING A SET OF
DEFINITION OF WHAT AN ADVANTIS
VERSUS ONE OF BUSINESS ACTIVITY
IS AND THAT'S BEEN A PROBLEM FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND CINEMA
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE IF A WINERY
WANTS TO HAVE A WEDDING OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THAT'S IN THE VAN HE NEEDS TO GO
THROUGH THE PERMIT PROCESS IT IN
AND HAVE THE APPROPRIATE TYPE OF
SIGN OFF. FOR FOUR FROM THE FROM
THE COUNTY HOWEVER IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT DOING -- A TRADE
LUNCH OR A WINE PICK UP PARTY --
FOR YOUR CONSUMERS AND SO FORTH
WE SEE THAT AS A WAY OF THAT'S A
BUSINESS ACTIVITY YOU'RE GETTING
YOUR PRODUCT -- TO THE CONSUMER
IT'S NOT ABOUT BIG PARTIES AND
SO FORTH ABOUT ENGAGING THAT
CONSUMER AND HOPEFULLY --
INCREASING YOUR YOUR SALES BASE
SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY ON A LOT
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT SET OF
DEFINITIONS -- BECAUSE ONE OF
THE OTHER CONCERNS FROM THE
CHARITABLE ASPECT THAT WE SEE IS --
LET'S SAY MY WINERY HAS -- TEN
EVENTS THAT I CAN DO ALL RIGHT
NOW IF I HAVE ONE A BUSINESS
ACTIVITY THAT MIGHT BE.
COUNTED AS ONE OF MY EVENTS
HOWEVER AS WE ALL KNOW ONE
REASON ONE OF THE MORE POPULAR
VENUES FOR CHARITABLE FUND
RAISERS.
IF I GET MY MEDS CUT BACK TO
FIVE I CAN TELL YOU WHICH ONES
ARE GOING TO GET CUT I HAVE TO
HAVE THOSE FIVE TO GOOGLE MY
BUSINESS SO THAT IMPACT ROLES
ALL THE WAY TO THE COMMUNITY.
SO IT'S JUST A THOUGHT NO THANK
YOU SO MUCH MICHAEL AND I WAS AT
THE ORIGINAL KICK OFF MEETING I
THINK IT WAS EITHER SEVEN OR
SEVEN HALF YEARS AGO ON THIS
ISSUE.
SO NO THIS IS BEEN A FOCUS OF
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M MISHRA
QUICKLY.
I WILL BE VERY QUICKLY -- ONE
THING -- I WANTED TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR SUPPORTING LEGISLATION
THAT'S GOING TO HELP FOLKS WITH
THEIR DIRECT TO CONSUMER -- WORK
WHICH IS THIS SUPPORT OF CENTER
GLAZER.
GLAZER IS SP TWO SIXTY FOUR
WHICH ALLOWS FOR ADDITIONAL
TASTING ROOM AND HOPEFULLY
ADDITIONAL DIRECT TO CONSUMER.
TASTINGS AND SO FAR BEEN GOING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
UNANIMOUSLY SO WE'RE VERY
PLEASED WITH THAT.
AND ALSO PART OF THE WORK ONE
INSTITUTE DOES -- THE YOU MAY
NOT SEE IN CALIFORNIA BUT ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY -- WE FIGHT THE
FIGHT TO ENSURE THAT -- THESE
BOOKS ARE ABLE TO SELL THE WIND
TO CONSUMERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHICH IS A STATE BY STATE BY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH HUESO JERICHO
GET ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO OUR
SECOND PANEL PLEASE NICE JOB.
HE WOULD JUST HAVE SOME TIME
BLOCKED OFF FOR ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS IF ANYBODY WISHES -- TO
SAY ANYTHING OR MAKE SOME PUBLIC
COMMENTS -- PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF BOB MIKE
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ONE GROUP GROWERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HOSTING THIS HEARING IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND USER SO THE
STRONGEST VOICES FOR THE
INDUSTRY IN THE CAPITAL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK -- THE
THE ISSUE OF CULTIVATING NEXT
GENERATION Y. LEADERS.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT -- THIS WEEK
WE HAD OUR SUMMER CONFERENCE
HERE IN CINEMA WE'RE THE BIGGEST
ISSUES THAT CAME UP OVER OVER
OVER AGAIN WAS LABOR.
AND LABOR FOR GROWERS IS A HUGE
ISSUE AND LOOK AT THE NEXT
GENERATION IT'S A COUPLE THINGS
ONE IS COST.
THE COSTS ARE INCREASING AT 90% --
MANDATED IN LAW AND THIS NOT A
COST IS PASSED ON THE THE COST
IS PASSED ON TO THE WINERY
THAT'S A COST MORE BY THE GROWER
THAT AFFECTS THE BOTTOM LINE.
THEN YOU LOOK AT AVAILABILITY OF
WORKERS.
PART OF THAT IS I WILL TRY TO
FIND MORE WAYS OF TREATING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WORKERS WERE
LOOKING AT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ALL KINDS OF INNOVATIVE
WAYS OF OF OF MAKING THE NEXT
GROUP OF WORKERS -- EDUCATED IN
HOW TO I WORK FOR OUR OF THE
WINE INDUSTRY IS LIKE A TREE TO
BILL COUPLE YEARS AGO ON THIS
ISSUE -- IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND I ARE JUST
CONTINUE THAT WORK.
THAT'S ALSO TECHNOLOGY TO EXTENT
THAT WE CAN USE TECHNOLOGY TO TO
BE MORE EFFICIENT AND HOW WE I
WORK IN THE VINEYARDS AND GET
MORE PRODUCTION ALL THE VENEERS
THAT CAN POTENTIALLY REDUCE THE
DEMAND OF THE WORKFORCE.
SAY WITH MECHANIZATION WITHOUT
WELL THE THING WITH -- HARVEST
READING THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
ALL OF THAT CAN HELP REDUCE THE
DEMAND OF THE WORKFORCE.
AND THEN AS USUAL HOUSING EVERY
ADD WORKER NEEDS A HOME AND
CALIFORNIA IS SUFFERING WITH NOT
ADEQUATE HOUSING FRAG WORKERS --
MANY GROWERS ARE MOVING TO THE
H. TWO WAY PROGRAM WHICH IS A
GUEST WORKER PROGRAM AND THAT
PROGRAM REQUIRES THAT THE GORE
PROVIDE THE HOUSING DIRECTLY FOR
THE WORKER.
THAT'S A INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE
PROCESS SO IT DOESN'T BOTHER
GROVER'S BUT IT DEMONSTRATES THE
BREWERS COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING
HOUSING FOR THE WORKERS AND VERY
MUCH NEEDED SO.
WE LOOK AT THE NEXT GENERATION
AND THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES FOR
THE GROWERS LABOR HAS TO BE
REALLY HIGH ANALYST THANK YOU
GET FOR YOUR ALL YOUR WORKING
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS -- BREAKWATER I HAVE
A SMALL VINEYARD IN REDWOOD
VALLEY -- MY COMMENTS ARE
DIRECTED TOWARDS A SOME COMMENTS
THAT TONY MADE -- REGARDING THE
USE OF DATA TO HELP IMPROVE
VINEYARD OPERATIONS THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM WITH THAT IS BROADBAND
SERVICE IN RURAL AREAS.
I'M I LIVE IN A RURAL AREA AND
MY BROADBAND CONNECTION IS
PAINFULLY SLOW AND I DON'T DEAL
WITH BIG DATA.
SO -- GREAT IDEA WE NEED IT BUT
WE'VE GOT A BIGGER PROBLEM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT -- I STARTED
WHEN I FIRST STARTED MY GOAL WAS
TO MAKE SURE INTERNET FOR ALL.
AND WE DID GET A BILL THROUGH A
BE SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE IT IS
GEARED PRIMARILY BECAUSE I LIVE
IN A RURAL AREA IN BETWEEN
SACRAMENTO IN -- MY HOME WINTERS
EVERYTHING DROPS.
THE LITTLE DIAL GOES AROUND AND
I'M THINKING I'M SO CLOSE TO
CIVILIZATION I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS WHAT IS.
AND IT'S AMAZING HOW MANY TIMES
JOEL TALK TO PEOPLE FROM OTHER
AREAS AND STAY PRIMARILY IN OUR
URBAN AREAS AND THEY ARE SHOCKED
THEY JUST ASSUME THAT WE ALL
HAVE IT.
SO -- OUR ALL WE'RE DOING THE
WORK -- WE'RE TRYING TO GET
EVERYTHING TO SITUATED THEY'RE
DOING SOME STUDIES BUT AS C. P.
YOU SEE IS GOING TO HELP US MOVE
THIS FORWARD -- AND HOPEFULLY
WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR SO I HAVE
MY BROADBAND QUEEN BACK HERE
DARIEN RAISE YOUR HAND.
AND SHE HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR ME FOR THREE YEARS SO -- I
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR BECAUSE
ALL OF MY INFORMATION HAS TO GO
VIA INTERNET FOR MY FARM.
AND I'VE JUST M. MILLER STREET
HOPING IT CAN CONTACT CONNECTION
AND I'M WITH YOU SO YOU CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A LOT OF THESE
GRANTS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T EVEN
GET ONLINE [INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE]
AREA.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING.
TO TALK PUBLICADO OKAY GREAT.
GOOD MORNING A NOTE THE JOB
LONGER FROM CONGRESSMAN
THOMPSON'S OFFICES HERE AND ALSO
MELISSA PLAY -- FROM ASSEMBLY.
LEVIN'S OFFICE HERE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- FOR COMING I ALSO
WANTED TO THANK ALL OF OUR STAFF
YOU GUYS RAISE YOUR HAND.
WE CAN'T DO THE GOOD JOB THAT WE
DO.
EVERY SINGLE DAY -- WITHOUT
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME REALLY AWESOME
PEOPLE THERE SENATE SERGEANT IF
YOU RAISE YOUR HANDS THE CABIN --
SO.
YOU'RE HERE TO PROTECT US -- TO
BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR HARD WORK AND AND COMING
FROM SACRAMENTO.
AS YOU GET THIS DODD WHY I JUST
LIKE TO BECAUSE JUST COUPLE
CLOSING REMARKS I REALLY WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU.
FIRST AND FOREMOST -- FOR COMING
HERE STONE THE STATE UNIVERSITY
FOR HOSTING US THIS BEAUTIFUL
FACILITY.
YOU KNOW I IT ALSO TO MY
COLLEAGUES -- BUT I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THE FUTURE YOU KNOW OF THE
WHITE WINE INDUSTRY AND WE ARE
BRINGING IN THIS.
TOUR AROUND TO DIFFERENT REGIONS
YEAH WILL GENERALLY HAVE A ONCE
IT SNOW MISSTATE ONCE IT.
YELL AT DAVIS -- OR THE OR A NAP
BUT BECAUSE IT'S CLOSE BUT WE'VE
BEEN THE CDA GO WE'VE BEEN TO
SANTA BARBARA.
AND WE PLAN ON HIS THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA WINE INDUSTRY.
AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE IT ON THE
ROAD -- AND GO TO DIFFERENT
PLACES AS AS WE GO AROUND THE
STATE [INAUDIBLE]
SENATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE CHAIR
WANNA TAKE MOMA'S A THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR -- WE ALSO -- ROTATE
HEARINGS THIS IS BEEN ONE THAT --
SINNER GUIDES OFFICE IS TAKING
ME DON'T I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK YOU CENTER DODD --
IN HIS TEAM ESPECIALLY FOR ALL
THEIR WORK I SAY THANK YOU TO BE
SENATE WOMAN THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE SIMPLY. FOR
ALL OF OUR WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING WITH US
ON THIS FRIDAY INTO OUR
PANELISTS INDOCIN ON THE STATE
FOR HOSTING US IN THIS FIVE IS
FACILITY WE LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH YOU HERE.
IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS TO COME
IN WE'RE HONORED TO BE HERE WITH
YOU TODAY.
AND MY FINAL COMMENT IS I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU AS WELL BUT
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNMENT DOES WORK.
AND WE HAVE INCREDIBLE TEAMS
THIS AS EVERYONE'S POINTED OUT --
IF YOU HAVE IDEAS I BILL IDEAS
THINGS YOU DO OR DON'T LIKE IN
THE INDUSTRY THINK YOU THINK
THAT WE SHOULD WE DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT TODAY.
PLEASE CALL OUR OFFICES THEY GET
ONLINE TO FILL OUT A FORM FOR US
COME OCTOBER NOVEMBER WE GO
THROUGH ALL THOSE FORMS TO
DETERMINE WHAT KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE MIGHT NEED TO DO A BILL.
FOR OR MAYBE DO SOME KIND OF
AMENDMENT TO AN EXISTING BILL
THIS NOT WORKING OR IS WORKING
OR WHATEVER.
BUT WE'RE HERE TO HELP YOU OUT
AND PLEASE CONTACT US -- WE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO MAKE SURE THE WINE
INDUSTRY REMAINS NUMBER ONE IN
THE WORLD THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT -- WILL ADJOURN
THIS MEETING IN THERE IS A WINE
TASTING IT'S GONNA BE OUT HERE.
I'M SORRY TO SAY THAT I HAVE TO
LEAVE BECAUSE ON FRIDAY
AFTERNOON I'M GOING TO
CONTRAPOSITIVE COUNTY.
WHICH DON'T EVEN ASK ME WHY ALL
YET FOR COMING THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED